howdy howdy howdy welcome back to
mcubed
sidre somewhere down here
sidre there we go and Matt the dean we
we've got we've got a trifecta going
today which is pretty damn cool I'd say
three channels for the price of actually
for three yeah for the price of three
price of one
right well we've got a few things uh
lined up for today the Creator versus
Rebel moon what will be the most epic
sci-fi of 2023 now that Dune part two is
no longer part of
our upcoming months uh before we do
anything
else thank
you happy
birth
oh was that awkward and bad enough for a
happy birthday song real
quick I me see more for you
too maybe in my brain I'm going oh [__]
did we do with this I don't know I was
hoping you were tagging on and we were
just like well well uh but happy
birthday brother uh you're you're 18 now
19 what was it yeah yeah something 60 50
oh yeah yeah
is no I'm I'm I'm
31 31 I I'll I'll reverse it I'm
13 we got to get off this things quick
then the stream cancelled uh when I was
31 you were 17 stream like
this you were 17 you weren't even
legally allowed to drink when I was
no I was I mean I probably was though oh
you drinking not legally that's why I
added the legally um before you do
anything else I spent 30 seconds doing
an intro earlier damn
it set up I didn't set it up right I
want to see how good this intro
is I did it
[Music]
so I didn't know you were joining as
well at that point I can edit sweet
simple uh pry simple
good I do like the Western stuff Matt's
done recently we we we've added a little
Western que on to mcubed and it's it's
been cool uh I don't have actually the
what myself an intro I don't have an
intro I don't know why I do it I
actually get M at sometimes stop doing
the bloody intro and I but I've do it
because I feel like because I feel like
it's a TV show so I I do it like a TV
show but I don't actually know why I do
it some people don't like it but I think
it's a good way of just helping people
immediately wrap their head around what
they're watching you know it's like oh
we're back in a sidere there is an
argument that intros do nothing for a
video's retention and in fact will
actually hurt it but it's branding so
like if they used
Poss but I think just do one that's like
two or three you know mine's like 7
Seconds long if you can't retain your
attention for 7 Seconds
I I I don't want you as a
subscriber so we're good yeah we're
living in the Tik Tok generation now
though you have to literally hook
someone's attention within I think it's
like two seconds I think the statistic
is isn't it like even like less than
that because it's like a thumbnail now
right or or or even it's like that
you're supposed to be able to hook them
from like that that immediate like
change from like the thumbnail hovering
into like the actual video uh yeah
because it it does a little pre on the
homepage now does it on mobile as well
which is a bit
annoying kind of cool kind of kind of
annoying a little bit of both the
attention span of kids today is
literally like I mean goldfish are there
going I've got a better memory than this
kid it's not it's like it's ridiculous
but anyway let's not get into that we're
here to talk about movies and well no
we're here to some song that apparently
you want us to react we do have a little
song uh we don't we don't have a little
song Oliver Anthony has a little song
Al together like this happy birthday
Matthew but but yeah the the most
popular song in the world at the moment
Jamie has yet to hear so we might as
well let him just join in with the rest
of us right uh this song I guess it it
is a little political but we don't have
to jump into that aspect of it we'll
we'll look more for
Jaime's reaction to this well we'll see
if we can get them crying if you ever
played Red Dead Redemption and you
wanted to be a cowboy this song is going
to be your Anthem yes so is alliver
Anthony's Richmond north of Richmond
when y'all are ready let me
know yeah yeah yeah you got one mute
though you
ready yeah you got it it is on mute good
point good
point all right you ready yeah
go wow I've been selling my soul working
all day overtime hours for [__] pay
so I can sit out here and waste my life
away drag back home and drown my
troubles away it's a damn shame what the
world's gotten to for people like me
people like you wish I could just wake
up and it not be true but it is oh it is
living in the new
world with an whole
soul rich man know the rich men Lord
knows it all just want to have total
control want to know what you think want
to know what you do and they don't think
you know but I know that you do your
dollar ain't [__] and it's taxing no
hand a rich man don't the rich
[Music]
men I wish politicians look out for
Miners and not just miners on an island
somewhere Lord we got folks in the
street ain't got nothing the Heat and
the whole Beast milk and
Welfare God if you're 5'3 and you're 300
lb
taxes ought not to pay for your bags of
drowns young men are putting themselves
six feet in the ground is all this damn
country does is keep on kicking them
down lord it's a damn shame what the
world's gotten to for people like me
people like you wish I could just wake
up and it not be true but it is oh it is
living in the new
world with an whole
soul these rich men knows the Rich Lord
knows they all just want to have total
control want to know what you think want
to know what you do and they don't think
you know but I know that you do cuz your
dollar ain't [__] and it's tax to no
hand call the rich man nor the rich man
[Music]
I've been selling my soul working all
day over time hours for [__]
[Music]
pain
cashy what you
think I think Stephanie's right we're
gonna get a copyright strike
but actually I I I think I don't think
they've been calling copyright strikes
on those because uh yeah only if someone
watching it reports it which there have
been like
literal dozens upon dozens upon dozens
of reactions
so if it happens it if what um David
said I think was it David yeah this is
true if that is true in a year he would
he would make 106 million no one two
three four 10.6 million
sorry which is
insane that's that is
insane that was painful what do you mean
that was painful I think he means it was
that that was painful and like you could
feel the dude's pain while he's singing
kind of deal oh because it was raw yeah
it was Dave might not have liked to but
at one point did he say that if you're
if you're 5 foot three I'm not far off
and 300 pound then tax dollars shouldn't
pay for your bags of
f yeah he then talk about God like three
seconds after
that now he just says oh Lord I think
yeah but I mean that's okay so I'm going
christiany but isn't just it's just not
very Christian just all I was going to
say but I'm British so we think that you
know tax dollars should we should help
each other so yeah I think it's a song
it's song about the welfare state
that's yeah but the people that take the
piss you know the people that are 5 foot
three and weigh 300 pounds yeah there
the line before that there's people on
the street and then there you got your 5
foot three people buying fud rounds with
their welfare uh money instead of weal
and we're gonna get somebody in the
comments say um I'm out like we did last
week when we mentioned Trump for like
one second but who decides then who's
taking the piss and who
isn't we get decide that's kind
of no no no there should be some element
of common I'm not get I'm not going to
get into this CL because we
there's got to be a line somewhere right
who gets to decide where that line is
yes common sense I I think common sense
is the common denominator you have you
have you have a panel of like I'm Sor
impartial people come up with what is
like the line based on common sense not
based on political favor not based on
anything like that's going to benefit
them but just common sense there no such
thing well there is because mob rule
right so this is how politics works you
have common sense that we all know that
if you're a one-on-one person how you
would like behave but as soon as people
get into a
group they will quite happily throw
anybody under a bus and call it common
sense it's just it's just when you get
group think people become numbers and
it's just that's when things go horribly
wrong if you had put it this way if
there was a 5 foot three person at 300
was having a heart attack in front of
you are you saying you would not try to
help them no no because that's that's
different it's about funding that
lifestyle that's what it's about it's no
but there is a parallel to it because
what you're saying then is is I would
help him on a onetoone level but my
country
shouldn't the country shouldn't I
believe in free health SN we should have
we should have free healthare that's a
universal right I believe that
wholeheartedly what I don't believe in
is having
a welfare system where anyone
can I I like the idea that anyone can
claim it if they need it if you're in a
position where you don't need it and
you're in you you put yourself in a in a
position healthwise where
you're I don't know if you've made
yourself incredibly fat and now you're
depending on the state for help you
should not have money given to you you
should have the help given you to get
off to get to lose the weight and stuff
so you can then be
self-sufficient but when they have a
heart attack leave them to it no I've
just I've just said I believe in free
healthare
yeah where do you stop then where do you
st place would you tie their stomach do
that thing where you can n their stomach
and they lose weight that way if that
was the easiest way to do it fat bloke
that that worked a yeah had we whatever
it was a band or something yeah
[__] load we it honestly skin hangs off
the man like flapping it's amazing um
but so so what what wouldn't you do then
what so so so he has a heart attack
you'd still help him yeah so so what
wouldn't you do I wouldn't give him the
money to begin with to give to make him
eat like McDonald's every single what
he's saying is he shouldn't be able to
get like disability pay and things like
that if they're not willing to help
themselves we be willing to being fat
I'm sorry like this is going to this is
going to offend some people but being
fat is not a disability and it's not
legally in this country it isn't you
can't get disability if you then have
fat related disabilities like your legs
just can't take it um then you can get
disability for that but you cannot get
disability for being overweight in this
country it's not a
thing yeah here it is so okay we're good
then
hey we we've agreed and we've solved
everything that was a good rest you talk
about let's move on to something where
we're not going to get
cancelled I work in Social care so I'm a
complete HIIT peek when it comes to
these things I was that's one of the
reasons I was intrigued for your
reaction to it was like what is someone
coming from this point of view think you
know and a Brit across the pond there's
been plenty of people across the world
that have been reacting to it but
uh it's more of a working class anywhere
but hones in on the US of course put it
this way I think there's an ideal world
and there's a world that we actually
live in and there's a world where you
people
start drawing these lines and start
dictating what you should and shouldn't
do because I would argue that you should
we should ban smoking it should be legal
tobacco should be illegal it costs the
country way more than um even heart
disease even the heart disease is
catching it pretty quick um so I said I
I would argue just banic why why am I
paying for you to have but other people
but people that smoke will say it's my
freedom I'm doing it to myself why are
you telling me I can't smoke so but I
just wonder that I'm not sure we should
dictate to people what they can and
can't do um but we should do incentives
like sugar taxes and we should tax
tobacco like crazy to make it exord we
should do things and sugar taxs I have
no problem with that at all I say but
then if you want to eat I remember
there's this woman she said she had she
had 11 bags of chips pie and chips a day
and and she was like I don't know what
to do about it and I can't help but
think just start with like 10 this is a
rick vase joke actually but it was
actually a genuine news reporter I I
read start with 10 bags of chips a day
and go from there sort of thing how do
you eat 11 bags of chips a day she 11
bags of pie and chips every day and then
wondered why she weighed like 900
pound I can eat I can eat like I I I am
fat but I could not eat 11 bags of
[__]
[__] oh well Dave then says alcohol's
bad for
you so alcohol and legalize
marijuana marijuana's bad for you says
who will you still kicking I work in
mental health marijuana in excess is bad
for you frust anything in excess is bad
for you anything but if you've got any
sort of mental health um condition so I
always describe it like if the door to
your mental health is slightly a jar
marijuana will kick it the [__]
in right in an excess it will it does it
is proven to cause Psy psychotic breaks
and it is cause to Pro it's proven to
people predispositioned for those things
if you've already got certain and
eventually it will affect your cognitive
ability it just will in excess but I
would argue that if you are going on
your lunch break and drinking you've got
a problem if you're going on your lunch
break and smoking marijuana you've got a
problem you know and and I would say
it's exactly the same thing because it's
I I would agree with that actually you I
wouldn't like I have no problem smoking
marijuana I have no problem drinking
alcohol but I wouldn't do it during my
lunch break at work the way those things
the body are totally different and the
way the body reacts to both those things
are totally
different uh I agree with you the the
problem we've got mainly with marijuana
is that we could because we through
hybridization we've did this thing they
where the the the the drug that I always
forget I always get it the wrong way
around is it THC and something else yeah
but the one level has gone through the
roof in the last 30 years or so that's
the drug that affects you that makes you
feel
stoned that's the drug that can affect
your psychosis it affects neurons and it
affects um uh neuronic action in your
brain um and that if you've got um any
sort of open door to any sort of
psychosis It'll like say it'll in
eventually yeah but the amount of people
with Psy psychosis or schizophrenia or
the things that
do make marijuana bad are such a minor
part of the population
like you're say that it's it's about
5% so if you're talking about 5% if five
if if everybody started smoking
marijuana seven eight times a day 5% of
the population will go into
psychosis we don't have that
because it's I've worked in midd the
Years M it's I know but is that UK or is
that Global or is that us well it's it's
a UK statistic mate but we're all the
same regardless of where you are on the
planet so it will be Global okay okay
okay I just don't know we're
all day I'm on the citric World Health
Organization sorry but he started me on
something I I I I do feel passionate
about at the end of the day I would put
marijuana and alcohol in the same booth
as each other they're no and I drink and
I have and I'm not going to tell you
haris you're wrong for smoking marijuana
what I'm telling you though is that if
you are getting up in the morning and
the first thing you want to do is have a
joint that's no different from getting
in the morning the first thing you want
to do is have a drink you've got to be I
mean wakon and Bacon's a little bit
different than it it is very different
if you've done those things like ever
like uh if you Tak a couple shots in the
morning H I have a stone a day sometimes
but I go out at lunch and get pissed up
and have an all day
sometimes it's if you're doing it every
day oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh but
like you said that's that's with
anything and everything you can over
drink water like yeah well it's called
drowning but yes but no I know what you
mean you go into um I had we actually
had a guy who actually stopped drinking
water because he' he he did have a um
OCD behaviors and he water um and I
can't remember what it's called you get
poisoned by something don't you if you
drink too much water it overflows the
blood and your liver's like and I think
it's your liver and your kidney they're
over processing in two different ways
and it's just like you can you can be
too clean I guess or it just wipes out
the good bacteria just as much as I
believe it it it Waters down your blood
too much it basically Waters your blood
down but then it's it's some metal that
builds up and that's what kills you I
forget yes let's do that but that would
completely Harris's fault oops I've just
realized that there's a poll section on
YouTube so I'm going to be using that
all throughout this stream how' you do
show me how to do it afterwards because
I don't know how to do it so let's you
need to be on actual YouTube to do it
okay okay movies just doing the pop out
Chat thing but yes we're gonna end the
poll now thank you for
voting I want to talk about later though
remind me don't let me forget we we've
got options real quick do we want to
watch clips of the cre
or have y'all heard about Rebel Moon's
two party I'm excited about Rebel moon I
I cannot wait for Rebel Moon
so as well let let's jump into that a
little bit oh howdy schmook what's
happening uh y'all check out the after
thoughts for Ahsoka last night episode
three a little more exciting it was
still slow for half of it though Jamie
we're I I'll tell you when you can hop
back in because you might not want to
hop back in yet I I tried to watch the
second episode mate and I hated it
growing up now finding the pole
tab right I'm all growing up
now uh okay so so Rebel Moon though old
Zack Snider and Netflix have announced
that it is coming out in two parts and
is what the trailer told us we were not
aware of that just that
alone does that make you less or more
excited for
it say again say again Rebel moon has
been divided into two parts it's gonna I
think release one this November December
and the next one is probably next I
think it's only like five or six months
out so it'll be like summer
blockbuster I mean I'm still excited for
it I feel like a lot of TV shows now are
being divided into two two parts anyway
so I'm just kind of used to it do you
think that would
hurt the film possibly kind of like Mion
impossible just was split into two and
the first part did not do nearly what
people wanted or expected it to do to
thought it oh it didn't like it it
didn't quite do Top Gun numbers did it
so people
thought a
movie it's a movie is it a movie
possible yeah Rebel moon will be a
Netflix movie it will be one that they
they put uh Glass Onion the second
Knives Out movie out for like a week or
two in theaters so I'm assuming Rebel
Moon if they want to have a movie in
theaters it's that they would put out
there for a little bit uh so fingers
cross at least Capital Cities big cities
film oriented cities will have it in
theaters for a little bit uh this is my
opinion on the trailer I couldn't tell
what the hell was going on I wanted to
and then the second I realized it was a
first part to a second part and the
trailer was that convoluted I was like
there's no actual story happen Happening
Here we didn't get any story beats in
this trailer it threw me off and my
brain since then has been I think the
Creator is going to be the Sci-Fi epic
that I prefer over I
like um do you think Zack SN did this is
that what we're saying I think he Zack
Snider this and the thing that Netflix
announced right after they announced it
was a two-parter was or Snider announced
this bit
was he's doing two director's Cuts he's
doing a director cut for each one so why
not just make it a long movie first of
all it's already split in two why not
just make it a long movie like Zack
Snider's Justice
League and and is it just cash and
vanity that he's looking for for two
directors Cuts after he split the movie
into two That was supposed to be one in
the first place because we know Disney
would not have split it into two it was
originally meant to be a Disney Star
Wars film it was going to be one one
movie now that it's it's in two and then
it has two director's Cuts with what 30
40 extra minutes if not an hour hour and
a half knowing Zack Snyder on each one
is that disrespectful to Netflix and its
Audience by just kind of dragging you
along more and more and hey you need to
watch this oh actually if you want to
know more about this going to the Future
you need to watch this is it is it doing
what Marvel does with their T shows too
quickly it depends because you can look
at it cynically and go have they
realized they can make more money yay or
have they gone in the editing suite and
gone this stuff is gold but it's 4 hours
long let's cut it into two it's too long
but I don't want to but I don't want to
cut you know the director could I don't
want to cut that out I don't want to cut
this because sometimes how often do you
see movies and they're cut down to like
two hours or even 90 minutes sometimes
because some movies they they think
comedies can't be more than 90 minutes
long because the audience gets bored and
walks out um but how how how many times
you seen a film you think can't wait for
the directors to cut because they edited
the crap out of that you know and it's
like so it's not often though because
how how many director's Cuts really come
out it's not like that's not like okay
well aliens the first aliens um you know
the second aliens movie the director
good to that is like three and a bit
hours
long um they could have even they they
could have split that into two movies if
they moved and made that now and the
directors there like going I don't want
to cut all this from spit out of start
it like explains the rest of the movie
but they cut it out for the Cinematic
release because it had to be under two
hours so I mean I I actually agree with
you but I think sometimes I don't think
we're going to know until we see it if
we watch it and we then go in because
sometimes you watch films and you think
that would have been great if they'd cut
half an hour out of that and so
sometimes you go the other way yeah I
watch recently I thought that it was it
was one of the superhero movies and I
forget which one there because they're
all blurring together I think we just
just talked about it too it wasn't Blue
Beetle though you didn't Blue Beetle yet
probably won't it might have been the
flash that were're thinking yeah that
would have been a great film if they'
cut about half an hour out of it because
it just certain elements of it just
dragged on so I don't think we're going
to know until we see it mate and then
end of the day if it's two two hour
movies but they're they're epic and
they're b b boom b boom you don't like
when they um sorry I'm gonna rant
tonight I don't know I like it I like it
um Harry Potter they split the last
movie into two and everyone
I'm there those are two perfectly good
films I think they needed I'd rather
have two 2our films one 4our
film and I think it worked I think it
needed to be done um and yes it was part
I'm actually certain the executives
weren't there going turn it into two
films and double my money
no where's your ethics I'm absolutely
certain they're going yay oh yeah I mean
marking Jay followed suit immediately
well yeah but if the directors there
going I need two
films we'll know when we watch it yes I
I I agree with everything you just said
it's just Snider himself put a little uh
a Twist in it all I guess just being him
uh that's my concern I remember the
sniders cut of Justice League was
amazing
but there's a lot in it could have been
cut down just a little bit I need
directors could have direct is good I
don't know about that uh did y'all see
Army of Thieves that's one of my biggest
hesitations as well is did y'all not
Army of Thieves uh Army of the Dead the
zombie movie he did uh the Netflix film
he did last year yeah GRE in places it
was God awful I thought it was the worst
thing he might have ever put to screen
um and that really and and and that it
scares me because he put robot zombies
he put smart zombies he put
uh aliens in the background of stuff he
put a lot of cool Concepts in it and
expected people to be excited about the
concepts and then completely chose to
forget the narrative and I don't like he
put stuff in that he then seemed to
forget to follow through with was it
there was a big chainsaw thing or
something and it made they made a big
deal of it early in the film and they
just never really you know what all that
was he was he had two or three greenlit
things from Netflix already that were
like all right if you do this movie
we'll get a sequel and we'll have this
other prequel series we're gonna have
another sequel series here it was it was
just because he had other things to go
jump into which I do not think is a good
excuse to screw the narrative the main
core narrative that you're doing and I
worry with that trailer it being split
into two parts and then there wasn't any
actual narrative in that
trailer The Narrative we got was
minuscule at
best I'm worried because that Rebel Moon
if it was supposed to be Star Wars you
know how Star Wars feels to me and and
although I do poo pooo on Zack Snider
nowadays a little bit more than I'd like
to Watchman still may be my favorite
comic book filmer in my top two or three
I adore Watchman I adore all of his
early work yeah but just
recent Watchman is brilliant though
because it's not a superhero movie it's
so different and I thought he captured
the tone of the comic
beautifully um but even that film you
thinking as a it's not an action movie
that's the point it's a it is a drama it
is a there's lots of things going on
there but if that was an action movie
it's way too long and it's way too
dreary um yeah so if you look at it from
a different perspective you know what I
mean if you don't look at it as as what
it
is if you go into that expecting a hero
movie you're walking out halfway through
why is that big blue guy got a massive
dong walk out um but if you go in
knowing what you're going into you can
appreciate it and you love it but it's
it's
long just I don't know I'd like I'd like
for him to get back to good narrative at
least like that focus is so much on
narrative that 300 was right before it
like I mean all the things he was doing
then I just I just worried we're going
to get an army of the dead or even I
just wasn't a big fan of Batman versus
Superman I still don't like Man of Steel
I I love Henry caval as Superman one of
my favorite maybe my favorite Superman
but Man of Steel not
but I I'm the idiot that thinks
generally DC's best movie is Batman
versus
Superman you take out why' you say that
name take that bit out I love it Absol
sense yeah the the the why' you say that
name bit and I'm like like going oh way
to ruin a movie in like three seconds
that's really impressive um but other
than that they should do a Jamie cut of
that where I'll just cut that out and
I'll put in a sensible reason why Batman
wouldn't kill Superman and I'd cut out
that bit when um U the the Android thing
comes through the comes through the time
portal
and Bruce I'd cut that bit out as well
because it's stupid um but other than
that Android it it was it was Cyborg
flash it was the flash he had a a stash
and he was a black guy it was the flash
thought it was supposed to be cyborg it
was Ezra
Miller that c comes through the time
portal and tries to warn Bruce when he's
sat he's falling asleep at the computer
and he wakes up was that Ezra Miller
yeah yeah I thought it supposed to be
cyborg he was wearing like some like
janky flash because he's like from an
alternate timeline kind of thing he's
from the flasho timeline you can't
really see what it is but it's a stupid
part of the movie
anyway it did need to happen because
they never followed through with it
anyway nothing they didn't follow
through with it at all the director's
cut for Watchmen is absolutely amazing
Peter so good so
good uh
so J frantically trying to prove us
wrong no
interested black guy with a
mustache very it was a very dirty Ezra
Miller from The Time Dirty they turned
out to be a dirty Ezra Miller as dirty
yeah but anyway
um love that
as soon as it comes as soon as Ezra
Miller appears and I'm just like a now
but then the Batman fight scene when he
comes in through the window awesome the
the Batman when he's fighting Superman
awesome you know what the cool this is I
I'll preface this with a little it's a
sarcasm uh you know what the coolest bit
of that entire movie was how like the
Justice League was got together
through emails he put the Justice League
together through email Clips it's the
most entertaining cinematic thing
possible can't really see that see isn't
that a black guy with a mustache that
is not Ezra Miller it is it isn't it is
it looks nothing like him it's Ezra
Miller it isn't it
is it's a guy not black either how does
that look like Ray
Fisher right go back a bit go back a bit
when you first talking that is not Ezra
Miller that is oh no I can see it now in
his eyes it's Ezra Miller I see in his
eyes Miller it's not a mustache it's his
shadow of his top flip it's eow what's
all that other crap around him then and
all like the thing because I thought
that was long hair for some reason and
he's got some really weird flash suit
because it's supposed to be the flash
from the future in an alternate timeline
going back to war Bruce basically about
flash point he's [__] up the timeline
but they never ended up doing that
anyway so it's irrelevant I can see in
his eyes now it
says it's a stupid bit of the scene of
the movie and is block out of my memory
that that movie my memory if we got that
flash The Flash movie would have been 10
times better I love The Flash movie
don't get me wrong but it would have
been 10 times better The Flash movie was
terrible I liked it I really did like
it only way could if he'd have started
juggling babies I I'd have been like
thank you yes I do I think I generally
think I do need to get my eyes done
again generally think I might do
actually I was I was having this problem
a couple weeks I was trying to read
something I was like oh crap in my eyes
done again oh God P my cousin Vinnie you
need thicker glasses it's a it's time
time for a new set love Yeah new set or
some lasc talk about all that healthc
care stuff right get my brother had that
done I'm all right with glasses I'll be
all right what did you call it lasic la
surgery yeah laser eye surgery they just
created they've just put those words
together um he's American let him go let
this leave
it that didn't need to be
shortened no no I've just realized it
might sound scary to get laser eye
surgery though Lasix sounds
like I got
a and get some
Las Las in that's we need a little shot
of lasic nice it sounds like something
You' got when you you know you can't go
to the
toilet a bit of lace yeah need a bit of
it and now she can't drive at night
because whenever she drives at night all
she sees is just dots of light
everywhere uh any light that comes in
after night it just like screwed it
ruins your your your ey it makes your
eyes better for a bit and then it
deteriorates apparently quite quickly um
what what it's a but plug joke we keep
talking about butt plugs on the channel
because we've plug channel for some
reason and I
blame stormmy because he's not here I
tell it was Harris's fault but we will
blame no stormy was carrying it on
stormy carried on but Harris is the one
that brought it up
oh sorry stormy he brought up the
Philadelphia thing and then and then
that's put stormy on a on a tangent and
then are lovely people in the comments
wouldn't let it
go I'll say this is a natural Journey
from the orifice to to where we've
become where where we've gotten one
small step through the orifice one small
step you eventually find the plug you
know there is that I and actually um I
think um shell was on wasn't she
she product a unique product um the Ayre
logoed one small step through the or one
last step through the
orice um mug nobody nobody else has one
just shell I've never sold I never put
them on the sale I just did it perfect
just for shell and not being a Stargate
fan I had no [__] clue why I did
it I could just imagine her opening that
one she just messed me going
what I was like it it amused me I'm so
sorry when we see Shelly in person ever
I'm just going to go like just orifice
the the it's not not all H the orai or
anything like that we're just or or a
fist or fist shelle if you've still got
it stick a photo on the group for us all
to have a look at your our office mug
mug the mug I was about to say that was
worded a little uh interestingly
there someone's gonna clip that um we
talking about
well we were talking about director's
cuts and rebel Moon and all of these
things so with the directors Cuts
thought process we've already been
down does it make you more excited that
Ridley Scott has said he has a 4-Hour
version of Napoleon and he might want to
do a director's cut for that is does
that seem more like an applicable
version of a director's cut more so than
possibly
vanity Napo A lot happened in Napoleon's
life so don't get me wrong but you know
the first thing that made made me think
about that is when I thought about
Braveheart um braveart ends about four
times and you're like no that's a great
movie it's time to go now oh it's it's
still going okay um there another battle
brilliant um watch that oh he's he's won
oh no no it's not done yet I kept trying
to leave the damn Cinema and it wouldn't
let me Napoleon's going to be like that
it's like that mate that comes around it
won't leave your house just carries on
talking you're slapping your knee like
right and they're like oh and they car
on it's like stormy on a YouTube on a
YouTube video okay so so bye everybody
bye everybody stor like says something
really interesting bollocks through for
the next 20 minutes right
well I kind of hope it's like Braveheart
because believe it or not it might be a
bit cheesy but it's great Braveheart is
my favorite film ever probably F I love
Braveheart and then Lord of the Rings
also ends like seven times and that's
what they're too so yeah it's it's just
it's just that you it won't end a bit um
but but yeah no good films but and I
tell you what um I I do think it's a
movie that's worth doing because it's a
it's a fascinating story and it's
obviously historically accurate it's
going to be a bit like Oppenheimer it's
not the sort of film you'll watch more
than once probably
but um but it' be yeah I'm I'm
absolutely certain be amazing and yeah a
4H hour version of
that a lot
happened do do you think that is more
applicable like does that deserve a
director's cut more so than like hey
this is your very first film in a
possible film franchise before you start
direct or releasing director Cuts
splitting things into two like get us
hooked first kind of deal uh I just feel
like this is much more applicable for a
director cut of a film than Rebel Moon
either part would be per se uh this
would feel more like Watchman for like
that four hours or something like that
because that's not a vanity project
Allan Moore's Comics
were one of the most well-respected
Comics ever made and that kind of
equated and deserved that extra
director's cut after the fact I would
feel like where someone's new project is
like okay it's you're looking into it a
little too much don't don't think of
yourself that much if just put it in the
movie if you want it there obviously he
has more control than probably your
average director does average
producer from a financial point of view
though as well I'd be there going we
can't sell Blu-Rays for love them but
nobody wants to buy Blu-ray but you
release a director's cut of a film
people like in a nice fancy box and you
know stick a toy on the front or
something that's that's how we sell
Blu-rays nowadays we sell special
edition director Cuts oneoff things
collectors Collector's Editions so do
the movie then do a director's cut and
try and sell the Blu-ray and people were
still about people because like people
like collecting stuff put it in a nice
metal case and you
know if I was Disney know somebody else
that's why that's what Paramount that's
what Warner Brothers doing now War
Brothers doing that they're doing
digital downloads but then they sell the
DVDs and they sell them as special
editions with loads of added EXT which
is what we do anyway but they do it in a
way that you can't watch this on TV you
can't get this on a streaming service
you can only buy it on Blu-ray you know
and it's like that's how to sell ity it
find out about the
bay until this numnuts buys The Babylon
5 the road home movie and then remembers
he hasn't got a Blu-ray player anymore
because it's do you have a Playstation
Xbox no I've got a newer Xbox and it
hasn't got a Blu-ray player because I've
got the the newer one the digital
version yeah so um
I've got a Blu-ray player and it's at my
Caravan in North Wales so I can't watch
the damn film until I go to the Caravan
in three
weeks I asked my dad if I could borrow
his Blu-ray player and he said
no because my dad hates
me someone needs to donate some money
right now so Jay can buy himself a
Blu-ray player in the super chats and
first person gives 50 Quid so I can buy
a bur payer thank you for don't don't
[__] Works don't actually
do go buy a Blu-Ray play tomorrow I
don't even know where to buy a Blu-Ray
play you could just play it online I
don't know how that works oh I haven't
opened it yet I bet there bloody is as
well there'll be a digital download code
won't there John you don't have to give
any super chats I love you you're my new
favorite person if there is a code in
there so I can digital download it I am
GNA have John Campbell's babies from now
on all comments are banned andless she
super chatting
unless you're John unless you John John
you can comment nobody else can comment
Super Chat and super thanks thank you
very much now or if you're a
member um I've got a popcorn power or if
you remember I've got a Carin in North
Wales do you not guys do you know every
few weeks I release videos where I'm
walking on a
beach it's because I've got a caravan up
North Wales and I go up there and I in a
couple of months I'll be doing like a
week's with the videos up there because
I'm going up for a week do do Caravan
with the furies John Fury Tyson Fury
Tommy
Fury I don't know what you're talking
about it's just a caravan made by the
beach
I
biggest right now it's a nice place to
go at the weekend that's all um but but
yes but it's
Wales North Wales it's
lovely I know I know well is lovely I've
Got U I've got Welsh mate I like taking
the piss out of whales so I'll just
bring it help me pay for the Caravan if
you don't mind that' be great so um
there's a lot of alcohol in this by the
way so this chat is going to go
deteriorate really quickly I've got a
bottle of wine downstairs I got for my
birthday that I've not I have opened it
actually that's a lie I took a swig of
it this morning but I'm gonna enjoy that
after this stream and I'm having a
steak what kind
of I don't know a sine something
that I saw um a there's a Tomahawk Steak
in Aldi at the moment for 20 quid yes my
my M sent me a picture of it she went to
Aldi the other day and I went yes get it
she was like
no I wouldn't have to cook it I don't
think I'm gonna fry P carefully
carefully I got like it'd be like a wab
Bago or something huh that Tomahawk I
had when I went out was oh I'm telling
you I at the lot I at the whole Tomahawk
but those Chi
and all the things on the side I'm like
yeah did
you oh yeah yeah 100% it was like 40
ounces or something like that it was
huge yeah yeah no the Caravan is a
caravan right so you know you know like
the um the what do you call those big
metal beautiful things you have in
America that they or
wagos it's like that no wneo got a an
engine and a and you drive it don't it's
an RV a recreational vehicle in it right
it's not it's not it's something you
would drag but okay you don't because
they're massive so if they're on the
road it like it's see you couldn't drag
it round they're static homes I've got a
static caravan it can't go anywhere it's
like one of those beautiful RV one of
those beautiful bullet things whatever
they're called Silver stream things
whatever but
crap C so it's it's it's a lot squarer
but it has got a lovely kitchen the
kitchen's nicer than my kitchen at home
very nice
but there's about that much space
between the bed and the wall when I get
out of bed so I can just about get my
leg
in um and
um yeah okay but it still cost like 40
Grand so it's not cheap and it cost like
10 grand a year to run um and it's not
cheap but I give it out you bought it
out right you don't rent it yeah I
bought no I bought it it's mine but then
I rent it out to
I rent out to Haven I've offered I I've
said to you previously I've got
a but I wonder when do you rent it out
in this in the spare time to make your
money back I may I but the what it is we
haven't been for the last two months so
I haven't done a nice video when me
walking on the beach because in the
summer holidays it's too busy and we
don't want to drive up North Wales and
summer holidays it's crap in it you end
up sitting after the time in the bloody
traffic um so we rent out to Haven and
we make our money in the Haven so it
actually doesn't cost us anything
because we make money to cover it on the
on the on the just in some holidays
pretty much and people really do seem to
be struggling to understand what this
Caravan
is it's just imagine imagine a really
next one is
trailer it looks like it could have
wheels but it doesn't it's actually on
bricks mine's on Wheels okay well Jay's
apparently is on
Wheels but the wheels don't do anything
because they don't move they complet
completely irrelevant right it's it's
like um I don't know I've trying to
think of something completely useless
then but um I couldn't think of anything
funny so we'll move on but it has wheels
they all have wheels but they're
completely
useless if they're only any good for
moving the damn thing every like two or
three years when you sell it and like
upgrade and they have to move them sort
of thing um I'm GNA share a link right
now this is basically what it is I don't
share that link Jay send your Airbnb
link out
there I think Jay's is probably better
than this it's a mobile home I think
that's what I think P power's got it
it's a mobile home I think that's what
you guys call him in it and MOB that
doesn't and but doesn't move um it can
move but it doesn't um and if they if
they drive them down the road they have
to have a big van in front of it with
big yellow lights going wide load coming
wide load coming because they're wider
than the road and you have to go oh
Jesus um and this has been a very long
conversation about my
Caravan it's been entertaining which
Matthew you are welcome to use it's a
marvelous site for children and cheap as
chips I pay I charge half what Haven
charge to friends so you pay two3
something like that I might even give
you a weekend for free but I'm not
P for ask for a birthday gift why you
can I actually actually I'm I should be
going to Wales at some point in the next
couple years because my friends are
getting married I might I might actually
ask you if if it's anywhere near press
that yeah press that in you are welcome
to my Caravan it might be I don't know
but I hope I'll have a car anyway so I
can just drive to wherever is because
Welles ain't that big yeah let's
move let's move on um what we talking
about real
Wells I don't murder anybody anymore
I've stopped doing that that's good um
it's really hard work cutting up bodies
man it takes ages you notice he's not
mentioned his um his Nemesis for a while
there's a reason for that he stop I
haven't heard him for a little while oh
those real Wells I haven't had to block
anybody on this channel for months and I
don't like blocking anyone I think I I
believe I don't think censorship's right
but if somebody's becoming dick um I'll
get rid of him I think I've blocked
three people maybe four people but I
suspect they were all the same person I
think they're all the same person um
it's not censorship though is it you're
just blocking them from from your
channel they can still comment on other
YouTube channels they could do whatever
they want
elsewhere yeah I was just thinking if
somebody gets personal or they start
attacking other this guy started
attacking other
subscribers and because somebody would
defend me and they'd start attacking
them and I'm like that's that you've
crossed the line now done you're gone
um if just wants to call me a liar I'm
like get in
line but um but yeah I I get that at
work every day so no stress but um but
yeah started attacking other people so
I'm like
n well shall we shall we move on uh back
to a little film oriented uh talking
possibly is that
what it maybe I don't
know talk about what underwear we're all
wearing at the moment because um I got
some new underwear and it's Pleasant I'm
just thinking that we've talked about
everything but movies throughout this
entire
video boxes or briefs what we're
going
commando commando what now I need a
little bit of cage I need a little bit
of support there I do not want my winky
rubing down the inside of my Jean zip
are we actually talking about I'm from
the
swamp from the swamp you got to have
open
air what's under J Jay's wearing
underwear with like little red hearts on
it special Valentine gifts Harris won
get this but I've got W fronts on and
they're brown and the wise cream I
genuinely that's a horrific joke but I
had a pair of pants like that when I was
a kid and I got bullied so because my
parents would not buy me um normal pants
I've not wor war W Front since must have
been like nine yeah I was like eight or
nine or
something we were poor we were poor
boxers supportive but
freeing um movies so the funny thing is
that this is not the first time we've
had that conversation sci-fi said don't
say pants Harris would get confused and
him saying that there was an entire like
15 minutes at one point where y'all
explained to me what pants and all that
was which was pretty no we have to go
through [__] sake we have to explain
this to the American again well I don't
know we need to do again I think I got
it I hope it's not called football if
you don't actually use your
feet and and that's does that's way the
convers you kick the ball occasionally
it's you know
anyway
Americans can't help you I've done a
list I do find it funny how most
everyone else in the UK calls underwear
pants right but in Liverpool pants are
just
trousers really yeah so they've American
they've got the is that they've
Americanized it yeah I lived there for
like what six seven years eight nine
years something like that we used to
call
pants we used to call some pairs of
trousers pants but it was a specific
type of trouser I don't know when we
then started calling underwear pants I
don't know how that happened but
originally we called some some types of
trousers pants well growing up as a kid
um underwear was always pants for me and
then when I moved to Liverpool when I
was nine and I said something about
pants they'd assume I was talking about
trousers or they'd say something or
they'd say something about pants and I'd
assume it was about underwear and I'm
like what are you talking tell me about
your underwear for and I've always found
it really weird
obviously now I've moved away from
Liverpool and I live in the Midlands not
in where did you think I live doley I
don't live in Dudley yeah you need to
remember put drop a
message Darby
Derby you said Dudley oh yeah no I meant
Derby by
Birmingham Dudley is by dley
not Dudley I think Harry Potter no I
knew that I knew everywhere else in the
UK pants is underwear so I'm back like
my roots again it's great now I I
brought this up as a joke and we've been
talking about it way too long so I did a
list very very quickly of movies that
are coming out between now and
Christmas and I just picked a couple do
you want to have a quick game of yayon n
let's do some yayon n yeah then we can
talk about whatever you actually wanted
to talk about when you set this channel
this video up par um
pantaloon pantaloons is that where it
comes from pantaloons because a
pantaloon is a type of trer I think
that's where it comes from anyway so um
has Blue Beetle actually come out yet
yes right so the first list I'm think
have you seen it yes any good yeah it's
it's super derivative it's more like
smack dab like in the
middle that's amazing that's like ding
ding ding ding ding for DC oh yeah yeah
it's the best DC movie they've done in a
long time the only issue is I guess it's
coming out in between it is new DC but
it you don't you can't really tell that
it's new DC so people are like should I
watch it should I not watch it um it's
good but it's extremely derivative it's
not very original Aquaman 2 is going to
be the last of the
pre zaz changes isn't it I think one
okay so Blue Beetle I'm not make this a
poll I've got like we have to do Poll
for too many of them yeah okay well
we'll do we'll do the last one as a poll
if it's a good do Creator or Rebel moon
for poll yeah Creator or Rebel moon for
Paul there you do right um these aren't
all Sci-Fi movies by the way I've just
picked the movies that that I'm thinking
interesting equalizer three to make up
the trilogy comes out tonight going
tonight it's I was gonna say it's out
this weekend isn't
it I was America he was get the week
before us I'm I can't wait thought the
first two were great can't wait I still
hav I I'm not gonna go watch it I need I
need to watch the second
one it's it's okay it's not as good as
the first one um Haunting in Venice the
new porro movie of Kenneth
Brer yeah me I love him anything BR
anything Brandon anything BR Kenneth
brand is one my favorite actors of all
time did you ever see that um uh natzi
movie he did it something called the um
the final solution or something that it
was called um all British actors
obviously think but Kenneth braner
played a Nazi blonde hair slick back and
they're basically having a meeting to
discuss the Holocaust and planning the
Holocaust um Kenneth branner is
terrifying and you know like people go
oh he's so scary but they're not no you
are repulsed by him all the way through
it is phenomenally good um honestly go
find I think it's called Final Solution
but I'll find it for you Harris go and
watch it it was about got 15 years ago
this film came out I love K because the
whole film is basically then them in a
room so it's
intense as hell them discussing it and
the one guy slowly realizing what
they're talking about and what they're
actually what this final solution
is phenomenal um The Expendables
for not a freaking chance oh I'm going
I'm going
right
okay I will I will watch it when it
comes out on on stream the third one was
awful but the first two were legit dumb
fun I hope it goes back to dumb fun they
are popcorn movies oh did not die
he birthday oh no he's back he's like I
was like he just killed over on his
birthday he's what just happened I
dropped something so Expendable for I
will watch on a stream service I'm not
going to S to watch it crazy in the
hunter I'm not going to love going to
see it I'm going to go into it an
attitude like this but I will go see
it I I I think it might be good I like
the actor in it though I like
Aaron I hope he gets
bonded if it's not I want be him yeah I
was told it's definitely not gonna
be yes
sir Joe just said happy birthday to me
so I said thank you oh thank you Joe
it's not my birthday but it's very
sweet so we're not sure about
Craven yeah just because it's so
different from the actual character
Craven the hunter like this is peta's
version of Craven which I'm not nearly
as excited for well there's a movie
called true love coming out which is
directed by um the guy that did Rogue
one um is it Gareth Edwards I forgot to
write his name down is that right yeah
yeah yeah um so it's a sci-fi movie I um
spoke to somebody that actually has been
working on it um is part of the editing
suite and he's been working on it and he
says he's an old mate of mine I've known
him years and he says you're gonna
freaking love this film film is right up
your alley it's not called true love
what's it called it's called true love
over here the Creator is that the
Creator what we've been talking about
working on it that's what we' been
talking about true love is what he
wanted to call it he just said uh I
think he said in an interview that he
couldn't call it that or the studio
didn't want call no I'm sorry I've not
read the message right yeah he says it's
called the cre it's the Creator work
he's been telling me about this film for
nine
months I'm so excited for it it's not
even funny that's that's why like people
are so pumped about Rebel Moon I'm like
hey let's let's let's talk about the
Creator a little bit more this is like
true sci-fi where where Rebel moon will
be more SCI fantasy but well this guy
says I I didn't TW that I've seen the
trailer for TR and I didn't put two and
two together that's what he's talking
about he's been honestly he's been
talking to me about this
film since before
Christmas and he was just saying I've
been done a bit of work on you are going
to love it and he says this is right up
your alley you're going to love it it's
high concept but action and um and it'll
make you think as well there's layers to
it sort of thing and there's no right or
wrong so I think that's what he saying
there's from a morality point of view it
makes you think um and he says he keeps
saying this right up my alley so the
working title was true love I really
just need to read emails
better um so yeah we we're ding ding
ding that's I don't have enough fingers
and hands for this just as many pops up
mate we're in trouble we're gonna we're
gonna have
arguments um I I put Rebel moon on the
list uh June two are we excited about
June two if ever that comes out 2024 now
March 15th well June 3 might come out
before June
two
well they've they give us more news on
June 3 recently um is anybody going to
watch the new
Aquaman yeah just for the sake of it but
ju like literally for the sake of an out
of theater reaction that is why I'm
watching that movie yeah I'm not
watching it I love Jason Mur I'm not
watching that crap um and there Spaceman
a Netflix movie with Adam Sandler and
the only reason I've mentioned that is
because I actually read the book that
it's based on when I was a kid and it
confused the hell out of me and I had no
clue what was going on um and but I
think it's supposed to be tongue and
Chek but and but this based on a book
called Spaceman of
bohemia um and it's
mental so we'll see what happens with
that that's a Netflix movie coming out
not funny more more actual like drama
focused I don't know mate I don't know
what they're doing with it but it's it's
the fourth Netflix movie I think with
Adam Sandler and this is part of this
because you had that
multi movie deal um and I think this is
the last one of it so
um I don't think there is a new
Prometheus movie coming isn't there a
new there obviously we've got a load of
um alien stuff coming we have a new
alien movie and an alien TV series
coming I don't know if it'll correlate
with Prometheus at all I'm sure it will
to a degree but
like to that degree I'm not
sure but I think there's some
interesting movies coming out and a lot
of sci-fi movies coming out but an awful
lot of movies I'm not watching
I'm I'm happy at the end of the day that
Dune did get pushed back into 2024
though I think it helps two different
things for like sci-fi wise obviously we
have the Creator and rebel moon at the
tail end of this year which those will
be like those big sci-fi epics which one
will win out it it at least loses a
little bit of competition there so
that's nice so hopefully it'll be the
big sci-fi epic of 2024 over Rebel Moon
part two um but it was going to go
against I mean I think it w six six out
of 10 nominations that it had for the
Oscars last time Dune part one and those
were all technical categories Deni
villanu who did amazing directing it and
putting all together didn't even get a
freaking
nomination uh so I think them pushing it
to March allows Christopher Nolan and
Martin scorsis with killers of the
flower Moon and Oppenheimer to kind of
duke it out a little bit probably bomach
and Gerwig with Barby a little bit too
those will kind of be like the big Heavy
Hitters I think for the academy and that
might let Dune actually get some
accolades next year which would be cool
I watched Barbie by the way did you
finally watch it that
didn't yay NE somewhere in the
middle it's quite good in places I had
to watch it because people kept telling
me about this patriarchy and the
matriarchy and how it's just like um
basically is inciting a whole generation
of women to murder their dads and that's
I think that's generally legit
um so I watch it and I tell you what
it's they so oh patriarchy bad
patriarchy bad patriarchy bad patriarchy
bad oh honestly it's just like okay I
get I I get it and then she kept going
so it I I can understand why some people
I actually think patriarchy is bad I
think matriarchy is you know I think I
think any one gender dominating another
gender bad but we should be a
partnership which would you know um I'm
I'm not the man of the house me and my
wife are Partners in the house even
though if there is a spider she deals
with it but if there's a strange man at
the door I deal with it
that's um I will deal with the burglars
she will deal with freaking spiders that
is the agreement we had when we got
married and I'm sticking to it I'm
sticking to it I have a plan though if
there's a burglar in the house in the
night I'm running at him naked because
there's no burglar in this world that is
going to fight me if I'm naked he's he's
gonna run away um run towards especially
if you wake up with Morning Glory you
could with your
plugs I I went quiet for about two
minutes there because I just watched the
trailer for The
Creator
yes Washington and sci-fi you've been
talking about this all stream and I've
been like have no idea what he's on
about no idea what he's on about it's
called true love and and I can't believe
I cannot you don't have don't understand
how much I cannot believe I didn't put
those two things
together I know one of the people have
worked on it and he says it's
awesome good that's what you want to
hear you want to hear that from like the
horses mouth themselves like the people
that were physically there that are like
yeah they captured magic I'm excited to
see what's on
screen uh
um I think in like three weeks 29th it
said yeah oh they're still editing it
they're still working on
it that's a
concern uh I he's told me that they were
still or at least two a couple of weeks
ago they were still working on it well
they they can do that up until the day
before like still
just
things little re-shoot or little little
Twigs here and there they they not even
it's probably just like tweaks on the CG
at that point I would think you tweet
the editing though can't you you you you
do the editing you watch it you think
that's not quite the flow there isn't
quite right that's what he he's an
editor that's what he does um so um he
uh yeah he says a thing I've tried to
get him to give me a few tips on editing
and he just says you're a hopeless cases
no
chance he genuinely refuses to give me
any
tips it it it happens I'd be in the same
boat he says if we start that
conversation it'll never end
Ed editing
tips uh Hayden Helia Smith I think he
just goes by Helia on YouTube
now he is like the G for
editing okay it won't go in I won't
learn I I'll carry on doing it the way I
do
it sorry people all right well okay the
the the Creator though just while we're
thinking about that
uh Gareth Edward did an AMC kind of big
old interview I guess they showed the
movie off early possibly um at AMC in
centry City last night and deadline has
a whole bunch of
different little video clips half a
minute long 45 seconds long two minutes
long uh and and they're all good I love
that he set this movie in 2070 and while
he was being interviewed yesterday or
2077 maybe and he said well after I made
the movie because he made it during the
pandemic I guess and literally right
after the pandemic all this AI stuff
starts coming out he's like I should
have said it for like two years from
now not
2077 uh which is just kind of funny but
that's where we're at we're we're
becoming a sci-fi movie more and more
every day is kind of
cool we are living in in lots of ways I
think we're actually we we'll have to do
a video on this at some point the the if
you look at Sci-Fi movies like 30 years
ago in some ways we've already surpassed
it
Star Trek Back in the Day the computers
were crap our computers are way better
now which is really it made like doing
the um prequels a bit awkward so they
like computers are way better than that
like today we we're gonna have to like
up up that anti a little bit but in some
ways I think we've already surpassed but
we haven't got flying
cars yeah drones is going to be the way
in the next few years we'll be having
drone taxis in cities well have you all
seen the actual there's a flying car
that like is I think just got approved
for um I don't I don't know if it was a
specific country or globally or what the
hell it was but have you seen those
drone bikes that um thing you're going
to be using the police in Abu Dhabi are
going to be using no it's a mo it looks
like a motorbike but it's got like four
dra drone things on it and it can fly
for about 35 minutes um and the police
in ABAB are actually like testing it at
the moment they're going to be using it
um and it's it it just looks like the
the like the motorbike from the
beginning of the first JJ Abram Star
Trek movie it's a fly it's a flying
motor bike it's insane and they said all
we need is like better batteries and
they're going to be this is the the
future but um I I just think we're going
to be getting like helicopters little
drone taxis that just like hop from the
top of buildings and cities and they'll
like and they land plug in because they
they can they can only fly for about 35
minutes or so and they probably won't
even have a pilot they'll probably be
automated
and that'll be the way people get around
in cities in the fut amazing and that's
like sci-fi man sci-fi [__] and we're
living in it we'll see it in our
lifetime I might need to uh confiscate
one of those I don't know how I do that
but I'm I'm G to find that'd be so much
fun that's that sounds like so much
freaking fun have you seen I need that
209 to get built I wanted that 209 I
don't know what that is
RoboCop oh oh I see I see
crazy stuff yeah uh there's another bike
that have you seen there's a water bike
now you can literally just bike across
the water and it just keeps pedal it's
it's the coolest J yeah it's it's like a
jet ski but for a bike like you just use
your pedals instead have you seen the
dolphin the dolphin submarine I was like
I think I've seen a dolphin no that's
freaking amazing right it's it's
basically a jet ski but it's a submarine
but um it can't actually go into water
very well so what it does it um have to
see if I can find it and I don't really
know how to show things on on the
channel because it's incredible I I want
one so badly right talk with yourselves
I'll be back in a sec
dolphin I'm
jumping yeah I know you got steak and
stuff to eat me yes found it I found it
already right okay um the jet powered
dolphin in
4k right how do I then put it on
so how do I now actually put on the the
SE breacher SE breach I think it's
called the
dolphin how do I do it the uh to do
these things is it the present share
screen and then you choose the tab
where's present it's in the in the
middle of the bottom uh of things we can
choose Matt before you go can you just
Google Dolphin thing and can you do it
please I already got
it can you play it
please that's the one that's one I was
just looking at and then you got to
go but I want one so much I just want
but it can hop on it it can dive under
the water and stuff it's James Bond
Man what that freaking thing I want one
so
badly no way
it's incredible I want one so if I win
the
lottery having so much fun first thing
I'm
buying it is cqu dsv is it called a sea
breacher is it I thought it was called
the dolphin but okay looks like a
dolphin I Googled dolphin and it came up
uh that's
[Laughter]
insane want one so bad
I I hate the I confused so
bad oh man I would have so much fun with
that
crap whale of a time without
you right I'm jumping out see you later
buddy I'm gonna be how do I how do I end
this on just my just just I can just
I'll just kick you out no no no just end
it on my channel don't end broadcast
just close your window well he wants to
end it on Matt the dean if I just do
remove yeah that works yeah it'll carry
on on Matt the dean what's what's on
we're going to be 10 minutes or so and
I'm cutting off
anyway I think that's worked yeah
I that
work have a good but see that that works
happy birthday happy birthday
but yeah oh and then there were two then
there were two I I want a dolphin right
now both a real dolphin and the
submarine dolphin it's
Lottery as soon as I win the lottery I
am buying myself a dolphin when we reach
one million subscribers I'm doing I'm
going to do that and I'll do a video of
it there you go that's that's our
million subscribers think
dolphin 50k is tats 100K tattoo 100K
100K something all kinds of things
apparently that's what we agreed and uh
that be awesome uh I did a poll on
secret Invasion that I'd love to mention
to you did have you have you seen it the
the Marvel secret Invasion
yeah yeah yeah so I watched the final
episode today it made me sad how was
that um it it is is freaking awful right
do you know how like they set up rules
in Marvel I think I I did a video on it
and sci-fi sometimes you set up rules
and then you follow those rules the
final battle seene sequence made no
freaking sense at all oh look thank you
so much David you're an absolute Legend
sir and uh it's going towards the
dolphin experence thank you David
amazing you're a Legend um right so I
did a poll on the channel
earlier um if I can remember how to look
it up there we go
um yeah it it made absolutely no sense
at
all um the fight so the idea is that
after the
battle um at against
Thanos he went around and collected
DNA and basically like had a like a DNA
collection of all the different
superheroes yep right that's not how
collecting DNA works but okay nope they
then injected them into the green dudes
that can transform who I'm I'm blocking
all this information out of my brain so
I'm sorry the scroll the scroll and then
the scroll just started turning into one
of the superpowers by the way and they
got this from the DNA was that the magic
rings appeared on her hand um because
that's in
DNA um and and they had this epic battle
and even though they had the healing
powers she killed him by shooting
through his chest didn't hit the Heart
by the way it was right through the
middle and the heart's up here but we
we'll ignore that bit as well
on no
sense none um it was worse than She-Hulk
it oh yeah hul um it got to the end and
I'm watch
watching and it was not swearing unless
my neighbor thinks there was a
murder and what was murdered was Mar
Marvel's Integrity it was that it was
awful so I put a a poll on I I think it
very well may be Sam Jackson's worst
project even his purposefully bad things
like Snakes on a Plane uh uh deep blue
stuff like that like it's it's he knows
where he's at with that and that's fun
this is like okay do your best and then
put you put Olivia Coleman every time
Olivia Coleman comes on screen I'm just
like give this to her like she's the
only person interesting in this entire
freaking thing and that's just because
it's Olivia Coleman's ability of to act
like she she's amazing I think she does
um kisi is awful I love Clark and she
did not do well with this but how could
you with what she was given like no no G
it's not the actor's fault awful Sam
Jackson was awful he just awful um right
so finally got around to watching the
end of secret Invasion were the writers
drunk and the end makes less sense than
She-Hulk but what did you think that was
the scroll that was theote we've had 181
votes uh so great loved it 4% of the
vote I think that's like one vote um not
bad but Marvel have done better 16% of
the vot
vote okay 10% of the vote pretty bad but
still better than most DC
stuff put the bear 133% of the vote
refused a mess that was painful to watch
56% of the
vote and that's being kind that's being
very kind I think Jackson to be honest
because it's Sam Jackson he's
only just without even talking about the
fight
itself what like like you just said just
start all that conversation off there
are rules set in place the rules
obviously were not adhered to but now
how are they supposed to adhere to any
rules whenever if you don't call uh I
don't even remember the scroll's name
Amilia Clark's uh scroll [__] that my
memory yeah I I I I should I'm usually
better about just keeping it in there
whether I need to or not and it's gone
uh KY scroll uh scroll y from now on if
anything happens in any part of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and the
vicinity of the Milky Way not just Earth
but the Milky
Way shouldn't we just call Lacy
scroll yeah K isn't it k k is her Star
Wars sorry yeah no she's got all the
superpowers why not she's Captain
Marvel yep literally indestructible she
um grows um um thingy arm
from
dra all grows that um I thought oh
that's weird which which I mean if we're
just talking about DNA as well like she
wouldn't have the tattoo and scarring of
Drax the Destroyer if it was just the
freaking DNA like a DNA works also if if
DNA gets spread around during a battle
you can't then go around afterwards and
swab it up and know what you're swabbing
so you wouldn't have a clue what was
what and also DNA breaks down really
quickly so again I'm not sure that would
work but hey let's let's ignore that I
remember there's a battle going on as
well like boom boom boom stuff going on
so then then somebody's like there's a
lab tech afterwards going
oh it's just stupid um but then
obviously yeah she's the most
powerful superhero whatever you want to
call her on on the on in the universe
now and
it's St honestly Marvel I keep thinking
Marvel are going to turn a corner
they'll get good it'll it'll come good
and they do a movie Sometimes you think
oh that's that's nearly good but
honestly in the last five years
basically since the end of the the
Thanos Infinity Wars
saga everything they've done has been
[__] how do you feel about Spider-Man no
way home it's
Sony well it's it's still Marvel though
it's Marvel Studios but I'm I'm I'm
putting that to one side and actually I
think the Spider-Man movies have all
been really strong the Venoms have been
terrible who movies have been awful
people like them I don't I just really
don't I love Tom Hardy yeah that's why
they've done well because Tom Hardy's
great in them yeah um that's a those are
two films that I think whoever's editing
those films is um is a stoner probably
he's he's he's probably one of your
brothers your best we take things slowly
and meticulously um no they're just
actually in that case yeah they C out or
or Coke or something yeah because it's
so like jerky and rubbish
and the second see I'm not ranting mve
tonight I'm so
sorry uh the second um uh [__] film
we're talking about with Carnage so at
one point he walks in and he's sort of
like and he sees carage goes oh that's a
red one I'm out of here and goes to walk
out doesn't explain
it and then um obviously Tom Hardy just
goes ah go on he goes oh okay then and
they have the fight what was that about
it it doesn't explain it at all isn't
that one the line is like well we had
like no cuz that Line's about a
Spider-Man line is is whenever they go
back and say like we're some infinite
being that knows all these different
like Collective multiverses we all have
a shared
memory I don't I think I guess that's
part of the Carnage stuff but like I
actually enjoyed the movies I actually
do enjoyed watching and the character is
brilliant but when I then like say when
I watch it second time and the editing
is just doing my nut and then you have
bits like scenes like that you just why
did you do that why didn't you explain
it why didn't you slow down a little bit
and make a slightly better film let's
make a film that makes freaking sense
there you go I have the same problem
with the Transformer movies that that
the editing just does my [__] n um
and and but I once I notice the the poor
the like the Rhythm and stuff it's all
messed up I can't it ruins the film for
me
um but yeah so I hate those films but
honestly like what like Doctor Strange 2
crap Thor love and thunder crap be
honest bit s Andoid but genuinely
crap everyone was going nuts over um
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 I didn't enjoy
it that much I enjoyed
bits um it it is too slow and it was up
its own ass a little bit um that it's
good but it's not as good as the first
two I don't think nothing like as good
as the first one in particular the first
one's a classic
um the second one was good but the third
one is isn't as good and I enjoyed
bits yeah yeah okay Mr uh fillian fan
over here did you enjoy the fillian
aspects of Guardians 3 I was about to
say because those are the probably the
weakest bits honestly as much as I love
just seeing him it's just like it was
just oh look it's Nathan fillian the
problem was that was like and his the
outfit was stupid the spaceship they
were on was stupid it just looked stupid
the film is slightly too long and I
think um it's too much of a
goodbye this isn't this great oh we've
loved doing these three films and oh
it's been brilliant bye and I'm like
just do a film real quick we might
switch it to spoilers just to talk about
this for a second uh
uh it was such a goodbye film and and
spoilers real quick just to make sure
that's there and everyone's got that
down but nobody
dies yeah oh it's such an emotional like
they're all coming
back we are getting another guy into the
Galaxy movie we are it's just want with
James gun but we are getting another one
that that's at the end of the thing
isn't it that's the the Star-Lord will
be back that's what it said which I'm
perfectly fine with but
like rocket didn't die no Gamora didn't
die nebula even I I can understand that
because she's a good character to keep
pushing forward but zo s has been like
yeah I don't want to stay with this very
much longer it's like kill her off then
kill her off makes give those emotional
Stakes there like kill Dax because um um
so Drax the Destroyer kill him because
he has said I'm not coming back I do not
want to do this again he nearly didn't
do the third one so does that mean we
just get Drax recast now or we just
don't have an explanation and he's just
off in The Ether like
he's been
publicly very negative about Disney and
and Marvel since and before he he only
did it because they rehire James gun
yeah and after the incident um and you
know it's it's it's awful so um but it's
it's not an awful film it's not a good
film the TV series though secret
invasion was terrible She Hulk was
terrible I actually quite liked the hawk
guy the one the Christmas special he did
I
I liked it besides the last like episode
really yeah that's fair um uh what other
ones have we had TV series can't think I
just oh um the the Miss Marvel one was
terrible really I've heard good things I
haven't watched that one yet uh the I
hated black panther 2 but you're not
supposed to because it was a it was a
goodbye to the to to Chad Boswick um so
you're supposed to love that film I like
bits it's [__] awful honest black
panther 2 had the same kind of uh
mishaps I would say as Guardians 3 did
it it's supposed to be this super strong
emotional thing and by the end of it all
these emotional beats have happened yes
and if you're really enveloped with the
film you might be going along and having
those emotional beats with it but then
it's one of those things the second you
remove yourself from it you're like oh
wait they kind of like negated all the
emotional beats within the film itself
like it's just it's just it just feels
like they're up their own backside again
it's just like um it's it's trying to be
emotional rather than actually being
like it's you know it's like it it feels
like they're faking it and it comes
across the story lines weren't great and
again too long if you come out of a film
thinking God was that three hours long
then you know you've I I can't remember
I saw a film not long ago oh oh Avatar
is a perfect example you come out of
Avatar going that was I didn't feel like
a three hour long movie that's great you
know
um but oh Scarlet witch series that was
that started I like the concept of it so
sorry David Bailey just mentioned it I
like the concept of it but even that by
the end of it you're just going oh for
God you were quite clever in the
beginning but it was boring as [__] I
was watching it thinking this is quite
clever I like this but my kids who just
like this is crap I think the first
three episodes and then the fifth and
sixth episode were really good I didn't
like the fourth the seventh the or the
eighth episode I don't know why I
remember it that specifically but it was
the first Marvel thing I think that's
why I was just like this is great this
is great really interesting I like it
what the hell did they just do okay back
to good back to good not really and then
it just ended think it was that I
thought it was clever but actually we
look back in it afterwards I'm thinking
I'm not sure that's this is actually a
bit boring but like said my my barometer
was my my kids would have been 12 at the
time and they walked out halfway through
the first episode and like I don't know
what's going on that's not a good Marvel
should be able to keep the attention of
a 12-year-old yeah I I I do love in Ju
division how they do like the different
eras of Television for like an episode
and stuff like that I can see why a kid
would do that like walk out on
that but also like going on don't get it
yeah it's Marvel it it should still
retain that audience nonetheless like it
should yeah should be able to grab a
12-y old or what what's the point but um
but yeah I I honestly don't think
they've done anything good
um since the um and I don't know why I
don't know what has
happened I I keep expecting them like I
said Loki I actually quite like Loki
that would hurt you know you really
hated Loki I quite liked it I quite
enjoyed it I really like the first
episode and the last episode and maybe
the seventh
episode oh David Bei I actually really
enjoyed
shangi I like the first I like the
second act of shangi the First Act was
like okay that's a lot of Aquafina I do
like Aquafina a lot but you're making me
not like Aquafina as much then the third
Act was the same thought process and
then also like CGI just crapfest it was
like all right we got a sky beam we've
got dragons we've got bunch of villains
that don't actually mean anything so
much fun woo so many Stakes like I don't
know it got annoying yeah one thing that
Marvel did do in recent memory I know
what you're gonna say and it was
good werewolf by werewolf by Yeah wew by
Night the the one nons superhero Thing
they've
done it was clever might be the best
thing they've done since Infinity War
like if not prior to it it was I Lov
that thing and then the guardian special
I really didn't like
honestly no I thought I was really
looking forward to that I thought you
know you saw the they're going to go
kidnap Kevin Bacon I thought that's a
brilliant idea like are fantastic um and
I but they didn't quite get the tone
right it was like it wasn't they tried
to keep it in
Cannon I think so they tried to do it
almost like a serious thing where they
should have done it just as a joke and
not taking it seriously but they sort of
tried to take it seriously but it was a
joke and and I just think they got a bit
confused about what they're trying to do
with it yeah just as a joke not try to
keep it C just like and and very tongue
and- cheek and just took whereas it
didn't quite work
don't know they something wrong with it
I don't can't quite put my finger on
what they did wrong but they did
something wrong the tonality I think
when you said that that's probably the
closest thing I could think of just
because everything that happens in there
I feel like if it was handled in the way
that James gun typically handles
things at least Guardians one and two
would be okay but I mean I wasn't
surprised after I saw Suicide Squad and
then Peacemaker and then that I was like
okay that makes sense which also worries
the hell out of me for James Gunn Peter
saffron DC um I'm not sure James gun is
the um genius that people think he's
he's not I I actually I think we've gone
over this once or twice but I actually
credit him with screwing up film
altogether I think he did something
amazing with Guardians of the Galaxy in
2014 and that's like obviously so many
Marvels that kind of like North Star for
just because it's as successful as it is
for everyone I was expecting it to be
that successful as well everyone thought
I remember when it was announced I was
like
really yeah yeah where's IR man but it
was brilliant yeah yeah and then 2014 we
got Winter Soldier and Guardians Winter
Soldier is like definitely Old Guard
Marvel it's like that feels like that
kind of like and everything past then
besides maybe Civil War and infinity War
which were also Russo brothers from
Winter Soldier every sing single project
feels like it's got more campy more
jokes per minute which sucks like 20
jokes per minute uh and and we already
got like Jos weeden's version of jokey
stuff like and that worked really well
for the Avengers and stuff though it was
sarcastic humor it was it was tongue and
cheek e but it was subtle love and
thunder was just comedy vomit and it
didn't work it was awful because it was
just blah blah blah blah blah and weird
humor as well the all all Hammer stuff
was just
weird
um ification I don't like that word I
hate the term um and I and I don't agree
with it to be honest I don't think there
is a woke ification I think there is a
problem in Hollywood where a lot of
filmmakers are very scared of being
accused of being an ism so they feel
like they have to um overcorrect they
overcorrecting constantly so they're
almost always saying we're not sexist
but I say don't have to tell us just
don't be sexist the more you say it the
more I have to question it like EXA you
know there is problem with a lot of
projects with that there is a problem
but
um um and I don't think you can call
love and thunder woke it was just
crap it was just bad yeah it's just it
it because it doesn't like if if it were
woke per se I feel like it would be
spending a lot more time trying to make
Jane into the hero and all this and at
the end of the day she's just kind of
like I want to die and it's just like oh
that's entertaining like great and and
and she just instead of like I want to
die and like having these emotional
beats that they could and should have
had because that storyline in the comics
is
amazing for her to just be joking the
entire way and just be like yeah I'm a
I'm G just pull the plug she like damn
all right well here we are I guess this
is what the movies brought us to uh it
was it was a little much it was a little
much everything and it was just badly
done my opinion but the
um it was the it was the humor that
really killed it and the and the and the
creepy Hammer jokes and things was just
creepy and when did they make Thor a
dumbass as well I mean not I know he's
not never the brightest spark in the
bunch but they made him a
dumbass um and like
even even when they make him fat Thor in
Avengers endgame which is funny and it's
kind of like it does take away some of
the character beats of Thor because he's
just gone through so freaking much it
makes sense and like okay well he's let
himself go all these different things
but even while he's at that level he's
like yeah I just lost my dad my brother
my best friend who watched out for all
of us from when I was a child up until
now Heim doll he lost all of his other
best friends right before all that
right before he lost his brother to
having to help kill his sister like it
was like a a lot of bad things have
happened to Thor and then just it
negated it right
after endgame that was the last time we
saw any seriousness to him and he was in
a fat suit and he was still serious like
prob he supposed to be depressed and
[__] um popcorn po just make a good
point here and I say that that there
isn't I I I hate the term woke mainly
because it was it means it was it was a
term that was created back in the 80s
about um race and and some right-wing or
leftwing idiots sorry um probably Fox
News thought it was a very clever to use
the word and it leaves a bad taste my
mouth so um it's now become a bad thing
it was supposed about being awake about
race and and the racial problem in
America and it's been subverted and I
that's one of the reasons why I don't
like it but it is popcorn powders have a
really really good point got a load of
it's not just Disney all of them did it
they had diversity Executives Executives
in charge of
diversity and I'm and and I that's where
I'm and that's where I am going I
actually do agree with the people that
shout woke I I think I like I hate the
term I think a lot of people
over think that because it's in their
mind they see it in everything and it's
not it's just not as big a problem as
some people think well it's like the
same thing like what was the word before
woke woke is literally I think just a
response to people saying that's toxic
that's toxic this is toxic this is tox
now it's this is W
that's it's just it's the next word in
the Zeitgeist that we've all focused on
and uh like you said earlier one is
group
think there tends to be a little less
thought going into it yeah we shout
things on the internet that we wouldn't
say to someone's face definitely yeah um
but I say that I do think there is a
genuine problem um in a studio if you've
got a diversity executive I I don't
think that's the sort of thing certain
things um I I can't remember what it was
now there they're going to do a reboot
of something I cannot remember what it
is but
um all the Creator talked about was that
it was going to be um diverse and I'm
like you've just announced that you're
getting this new TV show oh was xfiles
it was the xfiles it the xfiles re and
he kept oh we're gonna it's gonna be
diverse it's gonna be this and and um
the actual guy that um created it Chris
Carter was actually doing the interview
that Chris Carter is that I'm not sure
anyway um and he and I'm like you're
just announcing it why the hell are you
talking about
diversity um and I'm just
like that that that smacks Dr and that's
why the people that do get really really
angry about this that's why they're so
angry and actually they've got they I
understand it yeah I don't necessarily
100% agree with it but I know where
they're coming from you know you've got
two people at shout woko you've got
thoughtful people people that actually
see the problem and yes okay they use
this term and even I've started using
the term because we've got no choice I
don't like it but we've got no
choice yeah people know what it means
for a start um even though it's means
different things to different people
sometimes um but and then you've got the
people that used as an excuse to shout
whatever it is that they're bigoted
about and and that's why that that's why
the people that shout worker about be
really careful because you're being
lumbered in with these you know with
these people people that are actually
are racist sexist bigots and you got to
be really careful that you
don't accidentally dump yourself in with
the same boat of people um because I I
say I've had debates with people that do
use the term and do sh and do say but
they've really thought of and they've
kind of in the same boat as me and they
say well look they gender swapped
something or they think but but it took
away something from the story and they
shouldn't have done it and um and I'm
like they did it because it generated
clicks I think a lot of people say that
um they um will executives are doing
this to make a point yes they are
they're they're not working um they they
do this to um get um click soorry they
do this to um make a point and they
think I don't think a lot of executives
are on the moral High Ground I think a
lot of Executives do these things to get
clicks and to get interest because it's
the only way to get people talking about
their project and do it sometimes just
to piss people off because they know
YouTubers will go on about it but it
backfired for rings of power and I think
they that really did make them stop and
think they that they've gone too far but
maybe I'm being a bit
cynical I don't think so I don't think
so
uh probably not as good a ter as Karen
that's funny
uh Karen is a little different I would
think but yeah
like so we've all met a
Karen we all met many Karens uh yeah
there there are episodes like it's there
are ways to do it like I like even
gender swapping race swapping I
understand why people might yell woke
for certain things and
like if it is strictly just to put
someone different looking in a different
position like okay that's that's not
like doing it for the right reasons if
sometimes race swapping gender swapping
actually works really well in things
because it's like that character now has
a new perspective on something and where
we might know how that character would
generally react with things now we get
this character in a new light that like
maybe fits and pertains to the story
better now in a modern age or if you're
telling a new story it fits with a
modern age better now and you can kind
of like put that perspective into it
whenever it's just
like whenever it's the exact same
character and there's nothing like
there's not that New Perspective the new
context to add to something and it's the
same old same old just with a different
face on it that's when I I guess I can
understand people getting pissed off to
a degree uh it's done for no reason or
when you get like Ghostbusters with
boobs where the mo the agenda of I I
think they did they announced that a
bunch of people on the internet went you
can't have Ghostbusters with women and
the writers went can't we and forgot to
do a Ghostbusters movie yeah I actually
think the they got carried away with it
literally a third of that movie is
saying Chris Chris himsworth is dumb or
Chris himsworth is hot and that's like
literally a third of the movie yeah but
sometimes even like um race swapping a
character so obviously James Bond yeah
we've got there's been a big campaign to
get Idris ala to be James Bond which
because 20 or maybe 15 years ago he
would have been perfect he's I think
he's too old now but he would have been
perfect because you look at him and go
okay he's a black guy but the character
of James Bond Bond sve cheeky grin good
to the women but he could still knock
your block off and you're thinking
godamn you'd be a good James Bond it
doesn't matter got tail end of Luther
time yeah oh beautiful and you know the
actor would perfectly fit what they
wanted to do so that in that case you
wouldn't be thinking just you don't see
the skin color it doesn't matter because
the character it would fit the character
if they have to change the character to
fit that he's a black guy then that's
wrong I think because James Bond is the
character is thing but all he really has
to be is a British spy he's supposed to
be English and we didn't kickoff and
Shan connory got the job so um you know
it's
like I don't I don't mind that sort of
thing if it's done for a reason you know
like when they did it with starbook in
battar Galactica they made it Katy sack
off but the writers even said at the
time it's because the character was
boring we didn't want to do it again we
wanted to do something different so we
we we gender swapped her but now a lot
of Executives do it to get clicks
writers do stuff with agendas Executives
don't people at Disney don't have
agendas and not all of them anyway they
have their agenda is to make
money and to get up interest about their
movies and and that is what they're
doing writers have agendas but they
always have and we can go through All
Star Trek episodes and you go if they
release that today they would scream
woke at it the the the Star Trek classic
episode with the black on one and white
on the other face is not subtle it's
about racism um people would scream woke
at that there's a load of TNG episodes
there's one TNG episode about
transgender people would and nobody
screamed woke at that at the time I I do
think there's a political issue here
that people aren't we're not tackling
very well um
and you know until we
do if at the end of day if you go into
watching any project with that in your
mind you're going to see it you're going
to see that whether it's what you're
looking for in a good terminology or a
bad terminology you'll find it um
preconceptions affects our psychology
massively we don't always appreciate
that um how much it affect our um the
way we see things until we realize
afterwards you know um but I also think
there's been a massive problem a lot of
TV series at the moment where
there's
um that they're doing too much they're
pushing writers too hard and they're
trying to do too much with too little um
they're trying to get it's all about
getting content on and I think there's
been a big problem with um quantity over
quality in the last 10 years and I think
the only streaming service not guilt
yeah the only streaming service not
guilty of it is Apple they're the only
ones seem to go no qu quality first
everyone else is like get it on get it
on get on and I do think that's been a
massive problem some some writing is
been bad I'd say for the most part they
they are they have more shows than Apple
does for sure but Paramount is actually
pretty good about that too
um I did it on sidre sides nobody liked
it so I stopped
doing but I have opinions and I get
caught up in I get I get a little bit
carried away sometimes we all do one of
my favorite things is we are like
[__] we all have
opinions I love I'm a bit Lial but I've
I've grew
up I had my career early on in the
military and um and that set me a
certain way of thinking I then went into
the NHS and that's a certain way thing
in Social care that I do now and it does
ingrain into your thing that you know
you don't judge people that's the number
one thing in me I don't judge anyone you
know I've not walked in your um uh Joe
the new Battle Star Galactic they um
they gender swapped um the um uh starbu
character so it went from Dirk Benedict
to ktie sackoff um so um but you know
you don't judge anybody because you've
not walked in there you don't know we
all do because it's part of your
psychology our brains to create
shortcuts and you create stereotypes of
people you just can't help it um you
know so
it's I've had to train myself not to do
it and I still do I still see somebody
think it Pratt you do something Pratt
why is you done that or that somebody
drives badly in front of me so I'm like
that's a bad person I want to kill him
he's just made a mistake it's that you
know so we all do um but I try very hard
to the immigration problem yeah sorry I
don't I don't know what's wrong with me
tonight I really don't um the
immigration problem I cannot help I
don't on one side of me thinks okay we
haven't got enough GP surgeries we
haven't got of school spaces we cannot
take everybody there's a practical limit
not everybody can live here but in the
flip side if I lived in Syria and my
option was to get to Britain I would go
to Britain yeah I would risk my life to
get there you know or America or
anywhere if I was in Mexico and I was
earning 50 p a day and I'm thinking I
can earn 10 times this if I just go over
the border illegally I'm going over the
Border you know it's just like so I
cannot blame anybody that wants to come
to this
country but you've got the the the flip
side of that
is we're already
overpopulated but the way we live 90% of
the population of the planet don't live
anything like we do you know flushing
toilets a third of the population
wouldn't would dream of running water or
a warm home or you know an education and
all these multiple continents that
struggle with that on a daily basis yeah
not just countries the continents which
is yeah well we we we won the the birth
Lottery we were born in the right
country at the right
time um and like I say there's a lot of
the rest of the world that just don't
don't even imagine imagine living in
China today even though it's becoming a
very wealthy country nobody in that
country really has Freedom do they know
if it's a wealthy country even because
all of everything they do is completely
blocked and and watched and and and
you know you live in 1985 in the novel
1985 basically um and 1984 sorry um I
was one year old well um yeah but they
that's that's basically the the where
they live and it's you know
um I don't know it's just we're insanely
lucky no wonder everyone wants to live
there no I'm with you uh growing up in
Texas obviously
the the wall has always been an idea but
also wall like and you know it there's
perfectly reasonable explan explanations
for it but at the same time like put
yourself in anybody else's shoes you
know uh I I don't lean the left or the
right either one uh and I'm I'm thankful
for that uh I was I was raised a certain
way but found my own way I guess and it
wasn't with left or right side which I'm
I'm grateful for that but just I I tried
to put myself on like in other people's
shoes in other people's perspectives and
and add context to a situation because
if you don't it it tends to be just a
shouting match from one side or the
other and when you're talking about
lives it can't be a shouting match for
one side or the other it needs the
context it needs perspective it needs
not just our perspective from the US or
the UK or the West in general it needs
perspective from the people that are
coming um there aren't any CIT Centrist
governments anymore Centrist governments
can be some of the worst ones as well uh
I would actually say the US government
is very much a Centrist government the
right side and the left side fight for
the same thing they just don't tell you
they're fighting for the same thing yeah
we basically have can't tell the
difference between the conservatives and
the labor party in this country anymore
no they B have the same thing and the
conservatives are a little bit more left
and they have a far um but within the
part they tend to be quite Centrist and
they have a leftwing element to them
that they try to ignore in labor they
have think and they have a strong
right-wing element to them that they try
to ignore because they're trying to get
as many votes as humanly possible so
they're very Centrist and also the thing
is they never really do anything in
America though it's even worse because
what you end up with having is a
president that's a Democrat or a
Republican and a senate or um or or the
house or both that are the other party
and they all they took the Republicans
are very honest about this when there
was the last um they said their job
basically is to block anything that
Biden tries to do and before that it was
Obama and we just got we gotta block and
and then the Democrats did it when Trump
was in we just got everything and Bush
and like literally it's it's just a
continuous cycle of one or the other one
or the other which you just get a newed
government you get a government that
can't do anything yeah it doesn't it
doesn't do anything and and we just push
ourselves further and further into
polarization especially in the US here
and y'all are kind of getting there I
guess with some of your more vibrant
politicians nowadays we're
not we're not so we we've always got an
element of anger but we tend
to I don't think it's as bad we're not
as depolarized as some countries even in
Europe France is has a has a huge race
problem and a huge immigration problem
and they very they they're they're
they're not they they switch to violence
quite quickly we don't tend to and we
have riots occasionally we get you know
we get pushed too far or something but
um on the whole we're quite a liberal
Nation we always happen We're a mongre
nation Now We're a nation that grew up
on the Empire and trade and being
invaded a few times you go back far
enough I've got blue eyes probably
Nordic um my mate is brown eyes he's
probably French back going thousand
years you know so I think we're a
reasonably tolerant
Nation
um you know we love our our main the the
thing that we eat the most of is chicken
Tika Masala it's it's the nation's most
popular Curry and most popular food and
it wasn't even invented in India we
invented it so um you know Indians don't
know what chicken tikka m
is what what the bloody hell is this um
slightly racist accent um but you know
so you know we we we have the Empire and
then we're just very sorry about having
the Empire we're so sorry we're so sorry
we did
that that we're think but um I think
America has got the problem
that I think they're in
Decline um and I think economically
they're in Decline and they're desperate
not
to yeah um it it should really worry the
entire planet that America spends more
than the six next six Nations on
Military put together remembering that
two of those nations are freaking Russia
and China and you still spend more than
the six combined it might even be more
than that now somebody told me it was
the next 10 combined um and I'm just
like why are you doing that knowing
you're in Decline
um so you know there's there's oh and
knowing that the resources are becoming
more limited what's America's plan like
um so but I think I think we're a
reasonably tolerant Nation
um you got it
there in Psychology though this here we
go getting psychology lesson now we've
gone all over the place in this chat
next time can we talk about films
yes I have one more film topic but it's
not truly a film topic already push in
two hours let's see how that goes look
um in Psychology you got something
called in and out group thinking and and
it's like you're in my group and if
you're out of group you we don't like
them and they did a load of experiments
with kids and they like you had a blue
team and a red team and sometimes you
get to pick the blue team and if they
won a task they could either get a
something that helped them like get a
prize or do something that harmed the
other team and invariably they pick the
thing that harmed the other team like
they they had their sweets took off them
or something and invariably you would
pick to do that rather than do something
that actually like helped you yeah um
the thing is though the in group and
outgroup thinking changes depending on
what you're talking about so I'm from
talford so I hate everybody from
Shrewsbury the next TI over but I'm
English so I hate the Welsh and the
Scottish but I'm British so I hate the
Europeans but I'm a European so I hate
the Americans I'm a white guy so maybe I
hate black guys I'm human so maybe I
hate the aliens that are coming
um you know what I mean so there's it it
you've got these InCentric circles that
that grow depending on what you're
talking about um and and it's and a
perfect thing for football teams is a
perfect example of that is I'm a man
united fan I don't live anywhere near
Manchester um but I hate Arsenal fans or
something um but when England play we
hate
everyone so I mean it's those loyalties
switch and that ingroup and outgroup
thinking changes massively and it's only
if you when you think about it that
those become when you realize how stupid
a lot of our prejudices
are because it would change very very
rapidly if aliens invaded us tomorrow a
lot of racists would change their
thinking very it' be entirely different
like immediately which would be
hilarious like that's what it took like
because it's basic psychology we're
animal and it's basic psychology
you know um yeah but a lot of people
just don't understand it because it's
intrinsic it doesn't it's not something
we naturally think about it's it's part
of our Instinct so it's like our lizard
brain it's it's our
Instinct anyway what's the other movie
thing you wanted to talk about yeah well
I'm going we Bob made a good point here
uh but that brings us into a much deeper
version of this conversation um and that
is true our Navy and particularly the
American Navy which is vastly massive
compared to us does protect a lot of
things it makes the makes the world go
around it it is true and obviously the
military isn't just an evil okay a lot
of our technology has progressed very
rapidly particularly in the 80s and the
90s because of military spending the
Cold War was actually
amazing um for the world for the
advancement of the human species in
technology um because of the military
you know our space program is based on
the that we wanted to build an
InterContinental nuclear missile you
know the Titan was wasn't designed to go
to the Moon it was designed to Nuke
Russia you know
so there's that which I love y space
stuff but y'all are just a little behind
with space stuff that's like the only
thing you are behind with typically uh
British yeah we invented it our
scientist just went to America that the
Germans and the British your space
program is based on our intelligence
they came to us though just to make sure
y'all couldn't do it that was one of
those like little ah we'll do this uh
but skint um but uh and and the NASA
what is the number one nationality for
NASA
employees it's America and Canada but
then Britain you you hire a third
highest nationality in think is British
people we we have a very good education
system stormmy would probably know a
little bit more but uh I I love do you
follow Spaceport cornales at all yeah
yeah yeah a little bit I love that kind
of stuff I I just I love seeing that all
these different places around the world
are whether they're government funded or
not to a degree or whatever because
they're typically to a degree uh I I
just like seeing more people interested
in in space and things like that it's
great to to bring it into a the good
politics of the world is like
adventurers and things of the sort
learning and yada
yeah there's always human beings are
complicated we we have good sides and
bad sides and generally speaking I think
our good nature wins out most of the
time people are reasonable oneon-one
people are really reasonable you know
it's like um I I I think even except for
the most extreme like Kooks Clan racist
a lot of us might have instincts that we
maybe not massively proud of sometimes
but if somebody regardless of what Creed
color whatever they were was in trouble
in front of you you would help them and
that's true for most people if there's a
natural disaster any part of the
world we try to help and I think that's
when we see the best of humanity you
know um Britain is is brilliant at it as
soon as there's like a tidal wave or
something the whole country just seems
to pull together and it's like right how
can we help what can we do um and you
know and I think and and and and I think
every nation is like that you know it's
it's when we start looking inward I
think we've got a problem and I think
America starts look inward more and more
oh yeah I was better just you saying
that was like I I don't think of
anything if something bad were to happen
in California I'm pretty sure most of
the country would be like good like you
know or happened in Hawaii I don't I
don't see the entire
nation swinging over to help Hawaii they
didn't they definitely didn't oh what's
the state that's it's not a state and
they had the um DC no it's the American
it's an American protectorate but it's
not a state and there was a massive
natural disaster a few years ago
Samoa Obama Puerto Rico Puerto Rico okay
and um it's um and they barely did
anything remember they said it's not
States you're not eligible for State
funding and it's just like your
territory you should have something like
those people consider themselves
Americans and you're the rich planet did
nothing and and right now Hawaii as a
state for for
decades oh I was on holiday and we were
down in tenie and there's um there's
natural fires there and we had an
Excursion planned so we're like going is
it appropriate for us to go on this
excursion and I just kind up because I
was watching the Hawaiian news and a lot
of locals were there going my H is just
burned down and those [__] over there
are on holiday there we've got no water
and they're swimming in a pool what the
hell and I was just like is it is it
okay and they were just like don't worry
nobody's died there are some wildfires
but they're sorting them you're fine
sort of thing so but I felt a bit bad um
you know
it's the world's mental sometimes the
food also Richard are you are you all
right a tornado hit your street three
days ago you you all good is your house
all right
hopefully
hopefully um what was the movie thing
you wanted to
talk we'll end it back on back on semi
topic let's end on Cinema scoop
so just just while we're kind of we've
gone over IPS and things of the sort
today I or at least my My Generation uh
I would probably say about Matt's age
and younger like the 30 30 years old and
younger Barbies were not super popular
honestly well growing up the the girls
weren't going after Barbies but you know
what was popular I don't know if you
even know what this is but a brat doll
have you heard
of they did a movie and they did a
cartoon brat yeah there's a few of those
yeah what is your obsession in America
putting Zed where it should be an S what
is wrong with you people but anyway
sorry are are you
Canadian no did you say Zed in England
and in the UK as well Z zpm we
go I might say sometimes ABC
that's yours are watching Stargate for
you oh no I might say XY Z sometimes but
the point is a lot of words are supposed
to be an S and you people put in a zed
and it's wrong just because the Letter's
there doesn't mean you have to use it
constantly um yeah leave it alone well
now the letter that we're using
everywhere is X but that's that's not
our fault that's elon's um Ark of Truth
done easy OG Stargate
the original St it's actually if you
technically it's the only real movie The
Other were DVD movies which they they
really yeah uh but anyway there's gonna
be a Barbie versus Brat's
documentary and if the documentary is
already happening I'm sure the Bratz
people are thinking about a liveaction
film of some sort um there's obviously
liveaction poly pocket movie happening
with
Mattel so there already multitudes of
dolls coming to life within Mattel's
world will the next DC versus MCU be
brat versus Barbie and has Barbie
already I guess sat themselves up like
the MCU where the DCU can't even catch
up and everything they would be doing
would be playing
catchup
yeah I don't just so Captain Cave Man is
no I went on
holiday you can go on vacation I went on
holiday and Christmas aren't the
holidays it's just
Christmas right what what is what is
Christmas classified as if it's not a
holiday yeah it's the Christmas holiday
but we don't call it the holidays like
you guys do it's just Christmas
I I like calling things holiday but if
somebody says to me what are you doing
for holidays I will think about where
I'm going on
vacation right we don't call we don't do
not call Christmas the holidays I know
you guys cuz you've got you've got two
or three things that happen within a
couple within a month or so so don't you
we like to celebrate we've just got
Christmas so we've got
Christmas and then we've got going on
holiday and when I'm on my so if I have
a week off work I go on holiday even if
I don't go anywhere I'm on my
holiday um so I'm on holiday next week
I'm not but you know me I'm I'm not here
so um so we know and then we have we
will you never hear anybody say vacation
unless they're going to watch National
po Christmas vacation or um another
movie that's called vacation the title
we don't use all the different National
Lampoon Vacation movies yeah if you said
am I going on vacation in this country
you'd be like
what and Chevy Chase is coming huh yeah
are we yeah are we going to watch are we
watching the naal L movie which is just
not no you might say annual leave
because that's what you that's a word B
version you know you have to book annual
leave I'm on annual I'm on leave next
week you know me we might say that but
nobody says
vacation just a correct okay man I'm
with you but grammatically speaking
vacation makes more sense because it
just makes it less confusing you guys
are so literal about these things like
right you've got a bin that you put
paper in we call it a bin you call it a
waste paper basket so trash
can Trash Trash as well we said nobody
says trash it's
rubbish did you say rub you say rubbish
bin I guess instead of like
rubbish we say bin put it in the
bin if you the only difference we might
say outside bin if we want it to go in
the trash can we might go stick in the
outside bin we call that one a dumpster
well dumpsters we have dumpsters here as
well but they're big so a big bin we
might yeah yeah yeah yeah we we're just
talking about like the bigger trash can
outside we're just we still say the
trash yeah but no nobody says
trash um in the UK
um well I think uh it it's one of those
language YouTubers I I've always watch
to a degree and probably should watch a
hell of a lot more because uh my my mom
birth mom at least is a polyglot that
knows nine and a half languages so it's
it's up here to learn somewhere uh so I
should watch these things more I think
was olly Richards he was looking for
some like new YouTube title or something
and uh it was like the English language
something like that
uh uh but he was I think the I know I
know um start I'm
aluminium [__] there's an eye in
there there not aluminum sound so much
better than Al aluminium that's like
that doesn't sound like a metal because
there's an i in it there's aluminium
it's ium at the end not
aluminum you're just ignoring an entire
letter look in the Modern English
dictionary I think Mariam Websters would
would say
otherwise I legitimately believe Modern
English dictionary no the Oxford English
Dictionary is the English dictionary
that's like saying like the King James
Bible or something is like like that was
like edited by like a dozen people what
you have an American di you don't even
speak English anymore you speak American
well that was the whole thing we just
speak a I forgot what he he's had the
funniest little name for it but it's
like uh the English language like
bastardized logic or something like that
it's just like it's a bastardized tongue
but it is logical at this point which
makes it make more sense than most
languages
but I in the UK apparently it was
aluminum at some
point no no freaking clue okay I I
believe you but right now if you're
looking at this it's
aluminium with an i
m you pronounce it aluminium because
there an N next to the and now write it
down slowly sorry I think it should be
changed to what kaha said though
aluminum oh wait aluminum oh God
alumin mininum
alumin oh this is like worse than a
trying to say see an an
from
Alum that's awesome I'm gonna steal that
for I'm writing I'm trying to write a
book at the moment I'm stealing it
aluminium yeah I'm gonna be trying to
say that all
day American whisper spoken around the
world they bloody englishes English and
Spanish are the only two languages you
need to
learn yeah Mandarin probably pretty soon
though um because they all speak English
China English is the most spoken
language in China no [__] because
they've got like 20 different languages
so um Chinese is obviously the most
spoken language but for sure second most
it's it's behind Mandarin there's
Mandarin and then English is the most
spoken language in China because they
all taught it because they want to sell
stuff to America so they all
speak English is the is I think it's the
most spoken language in most of India
but we used to own it so that's why but
they all speak English most Indians
speak English better than I do
definitely speak English better than you
do you bloody American but
him the illuminum was
first
yeah I had to put that up the second you
said bloody American just you know we
had
to we had
a Americans are like the stupid cousin
you love them but you wouldn't like let
them borrow a car
what I mean it's like I love you guys
but I wouldn't lend you my car I don't
think I'd let y'all borrow my car
honestly we we actually have land to
drive on and we know how to actually
drive versus like everything's a city or
everything's an island like we know how
to actually drive well yeah you just
drive in a straight line we actually
have to like do no no no no we have we
have mountains and plains and and swamps
marshes we have multip we have multiple
types of mountains throughout this
country we have a traffic Island every
30 meters it's law um I'm pretty sure
our councils all had like
um you know like curved they somebody
invented a curved piece of you know
curb and um and I think our councilors
like bought too many so they're like oh
Jesus we meant to buy a thousand and we
bought a million by accident right put
an island every 30 meters and then they
bought too many traffic lights they put
traffic lights on them all as well but
you have to um yeah this is weird sorry
um we're trying I just cting things
before I stop ranting about traffic ises
we are trying to get people to go and
subscribe to
mcubed um mcubed does brilliant live
videos every day loads of movies
about um sorry all the movie news all
this sort of thing and you've only got
like 270 subscribers or something not
even that we're working on it though
we're working on it but it's so
undeserved so guys sidet trackers for
the love of God we love Harris he's our
lovable American Idiot go and subscribe
to The Lovable American idiots YouTube
channel right now I get to be the Green
Day for I oh I'm kind of Green Day the
the American Idiot and I I like my green
if you haven't
noticed but I mean you do way more M new
a movie opinion than we do on SRE so I
mean you're our
um but you you you should be should have
loads more so let's get let's get the
bloody let's get you on we got decent
production quality we've got fun panels
we got all kinds of stuff come on yeah
no you do you make better videos than ID
um and so I mean yeah you you should be
so yeah that's why we're doing a double
stream we're going to get you guys
hooked and then eventually we'll just
move over to mq I think and just do
these Wednesday lives and and and where
would you go and talk about traffic
Islands underpant
um listen to me rant randomly and
talking epic
debates and sometimes I even say things
I
mean sometimes not just trying to wind
people up some
sometimes um but yeah we have to drive
in this country because we're on the
wrong side of the road as well you know
how much concentration it takes to drive
on the wrong side of the road all day
every day the rest of the world well
that's why you have to stop so much
right yeah we just keep driving yeah
well literally the rest of the world we
decided we're going to drive on the uh I
have to think which side we have to
drive on we drive on the left and the
entire rest of the world went no and
drive on the right and O British went
well we're just gonna keep doing it no
point go we could swap nope no like no
[__] [__] the rest of the world and
anybody that wants to sell a car in this
country will have to do a conversion and
put these wheel on the other
side like nope not doing it how
confusing would it be to put how can do
do people still have like americanmade
cars with the right side or with the
left side wheel it's very rare what they
do is they can they they they have to no
you can buy American cars in this
country that drive on the wrong side but
it's incredibly dangerous and it would
imagine going to like just something
silly like going to a McDonald's you
know go to a drive-thru you wouldn't be
able to like order the or go into like
um you know the toll and you know pay a
toll
like know so you wouldn't be able to so
but also I mean when you're driving you
can't see anything because you're on the
the steering wheel's on the you know
you're on the you're on the outside of
the um Road basically so you can't stick
so so very occasionally you'll see like
a classic American car and it's with a
steering wheel on the wrong side um
but generally speaking they can they
they have to swap them I don't think
it's a law but you just we just wouldn't
buy them it'd be so dangerous um but
most cars they're built in a way that
it's very easy just to swap them it's
just it's just matter like literally
like and and you just just swap it most
electric cars it's it's five by wire
anyway so it doesn't matter where the
bloody steering wheel goes that makes
sense it'll all be in the middle sooner
and later yeah probably but um but yeah
it's um
yeah I just love that we just stuck our
fingers in our ears and went no not
doing it we're not
swapping like everybody else went
completely a different way it threw me
off when I was in South Africa and in
Zambia I guess it's all the places y'all
have taken over I guess different
there's a few Nations that swapped
because we we told them they they were
left uh side of the road and then in
Italy when I went last year it was right
side of the road and I was like Veronica
what what what's going on and she's just
like yeah no it's right side of the road
we never we never invaded Italy no
except they invaded others and then they
also have had like 60 different
governments since the 40s but you know I
think we have invaded him once or twice
actually it happens it happens um World
War II we definitely invaded him but um
but yeah I might once I just I just love
that Britain has basically had a fight
with every nation on the planet at some
point or is there one that youall
haven't had that like has not been new
since since there's a couple that
because they're new yeah like since
World War II pre World War II countries
have y'all not fought somebody what
countries Britain not
fought um only 22 countries have never
been invaded by
Britain out of like the 188 or whatever
like um yeah so we have never invaded
Andor bellarus Bolivia Burundi Central
African Republic Chad Congo um I can't
believe we've never invaded Chad or
Congo we must have
around them they must not have existed
yeah I was about say the Ivory
Coast kistan never heard of it we've
never invaded
lonstein who knew H
Luxenberg the Marshal Islands we've
never invaded martial Island sound like
we named it there's nothing there either
we've never invaded Mongolia because we
can't be asked climbing that many
mountains we'd have looked at and gone
wow that's that's high can't be bothered
with that
Paraguay South ran Principe which is not
even a country they've made that up
we've never invaded Sweden weird it's
too cold tajan usbekistan and we've
never invaded the Vatican
City oh y should change that one I
didn't say anything huh um we should do
that for fun we should just send one
soldier to all these places just and
invade them as a joke just we go in and
go we're invad in and now we're going to
go and then there's back out so thing go
thank you much just that we can
eventually say we've invaded
everybody just you know put put your
like War prisoners on a boat and let
them do it and just dress them up as
Brits and be like it counts and when did
we invade
Greenland what were we doing I would
have thought y'all would have probably
invaded Greenland more often than not
just for the sake of having extra
land I think we've invaded some of these
because we've just invaded like parts of
their Nations I don't think we
technically invaded America did we we we
created it
well no you invaded in
1812 we're fighty little buggers we must
have been drinking just before we're
fighty when we get we have a beer we do
get a bit fighty I've noticed it's it's
funny yeah it's
entertaining day we have a few
jars
so is the British Empire is as cool as
the Mongolian Empire if they've never
defeated the Mongols
we were
bigger but I mean but we had like trains
and boats and airplanes they had horses
and it was quite big so Mongol was
probably the most successful Empire in
history but
um was was
Mongolia we've or was it the a was
because the Russian Empire kind of
turned into the ottoman to a degree like
Eastern uh part of Russia not Russia
sorry uh Roman
[Music]
um I don't know what what would
technically be the most successful
Empire it would have to be the Brits
wouldn't it the British Empire is the
most successful at one point we
controlled a quarter of the population
of the
planet um and and but we did it we did
we never really like fought people
particularly we turned up with India and
we basically bought it we we we bought
off the um we never we didn't go in vast
armies and kill millions of people we
just we went in
and we sort of went to the uh Mahar Ares
do you want to be British and they would
went oh don't know because here a
crapload of gold oh okay and they so we
kind of bought the country um we
obviously we invaded like a lot of
African nations and things and they
fought back but we didn't do a lot of
like invading we should sort of turned
up there's an Eddie isard joke actually
he said um we'd go in and we so we so we
turn up on a new nation we find a new
population go hello how are you and they
s of go oh we're lovely and do you have
a flag and the the the nation there
would go what's a flag go you haven't
got a flag and then we would be like
you're British Now isn't that lovely is
it nice that's um and and that's how we
took over the world um obviously we
never really fought the Americans until
you know you decided you didn't want to
pay for our tea anymore um and and we
had a bit of a thing honestly if we'd
have been um a little bit more
diplomatic
America would still be British now and
well it wouldn't be now but you'd got
independence at some point but you would
have they didn't really want to be
independent at the time they were just
sick of paying taxes oh no no there it
was it was a good CH there was a
movement I'm being a little bit unfair
but it got a lot of momentum because of
that yeah there were still like I think
it was 133% of the population or
something like that was were teres I
think what they called them uh which
they were like we still want to be with
the crown we want to be with the crown
but when it's only 13 and it's like 80
plus perent are
like yeah I think a lot of the
motivation came from the fact that we
were taxing you so heavily and there was
at the end of the day if we' we had you
could be like Canada now you could you
could be a free you'd be a free Nation
but the king could still be a head of
state sort of thing that could have
happened religion I think is the thing
that really pushed us though because
there was so many Protestants that
started the us and it was a religious
thing that made us leave uh obviously
we've grown into a not so religious kind
of place um but yeah there's population
things that as well when there and then
yeah which they were some crazy folk
that going into their history like oh
wow all right um there is a theory that
actually the British Empire never fell
we just privatized and that actually
America is still today controlled by um
some of the massive families that
traveled over from Britain um and and
Europe the rest of Europe as well um and
that we basically just created a
privatized nation and actually i' um you
know you go through the the the logic of
it kind of makes
sense yeah I gotta go um but but yeah so
yeah like the what is a crumpet yeah
sorry um right it's so it's a little
round
bready um uh thing that you toast you
got to burn the crap out of it because
it goes crispy and it's lovely um but
it's it's basically like a very airy
bread so there's lots of holes in it and
it's very floaty and light and it's
lovely but it's bread B shro tea is also
lovely yes and so is the American
Constitution for the most part for the
most part um your American Constitution
is lovely in theory but I'm going to
stop that sentence there because I want
to keep some of my American
subscribers uh and okay okay well one
one one word do you believe that America
has democracy oh no we never have it's a
national Republic obiously well you
fight for democracy a lot but even
though do you
actually do you even have a
republic by a technicality
maybe you it can call a public and it
was designed as a republic you have you
do not have democracy and you do not
have you're not in a republic um it is
Twisted into this presidential system
which um and democracy as well is based
on the fact that you vote and the person
that gets the most votes gets the
presidency that's not how your election
system works at all and in theory
because you've got those um idiots in
those colleges that actually do the vote
and there is nothing in the Constitution
that says those people have to actually
then vote for the person that you voted
for in that area they can vote for
whoever they like
that isn't a a democracy in in any in
anybody's understanding I'm happy that
it's not in that degree I don't
democracy
is disturbing at the end of the day it's
three sheep and or it's three wolves and
a sheep voting on what's for dinner
technically I I I I know it this is more
of a polarizing sentence but gang rape
is democracy like I democracy is is is
not a good thing uh a democracy is a
brilliant thing if you actually have a
system that is can be if you have a
parliament system that is the closest we
have to
democracy um because democracy is true
democracy you'd have mob Rule and it's
like big brother is a democracy in in
theory you know like reality TV is a
democracy in theory and it's not good um
people individuals are very intelligent
people are thick as pig [__] um you know
we shouldn't have democracy we need
checks and Bal bces definitely to stop
mob rule you know when something bad
happens you know there's a murder kill
him there's a mob we're like yeah kill
him and then Cal heads rule goes no
let's have some justice shall we and
that's what we need we need you know we
need intelligence and we need checks and
balances against our own emotional
things we all do things when we're angry
we regret later you know um but I just
think that the world needs
um I just think the American system is
basically a business you don't have
government you have a
business and I am a monarchist I'm sorry
but I am um I like having a monarchy the
monarchy shouldn't be in have any power
whatsoever but I like the monarchy I
like that we have a monarchy I like the
queen I've met the king I've met the
queen um I say met I was in the same
room as him and I'm quite proud of Al
Mony it wasn't near an Ireland was it no
I wasn't in Ireland I was in London at
the time but um um they shouldn't have
any power whatsoever I it's just a
Nostalgia thing and it's just a history
thing I like it but the parliament
system is the closest thing I think to
our big government and big business does
not affect our government
um even a tenth what it affects American
government it's you basically have a um
a business not a
government yeah and one that's not doing
too well at the moment
um and it's yeah there is all time in
this country though when um a a
politician gets caught lying and they
have to resign they will resign and a
lot of the time they'll lose their
Parliament seat as well so they have to
actually and we have to have a um like a
flash election it doesn't happen very
often because our politicians have got
very good at not answering questions
because if they got caught lying um they
uh there'll be a scandal yeah but yeah
but they'd lose their job yeah your
politicians can't lose their
job it's very very difficult to um kick
out to get somebody um out um your
president gets um you know gets what's
that thing impeached they don't lose
their job it's almost impossible so um
you know even senators and things they
have to die to to lose their job well
they die their
wives um take over until the next vote
that's mental that wouldn't happen in
this country um so you know there's
there's that but um our our they can get
if there's a major Scandal they get
caught lying so what they do is they've
just got very very good at not answering
the
question and so then you know you get
asked question you're like well that's a
very interesting question and and they
just go around in a big circle and they
go by the end of it you go you've not
said anything you talk about three but
they've got really good at that American
thing they can lie all the
time no problem at all
[Music]
yeah
yeah but yeah uh the the president kind
of plays a similar role he can enact I
guess martial law but the likelihood of
that happening there has to be reasoning
for the martial law or it's unjust um we
have a pro we have something in this
country sometimes call a hung Parliament
and it's basically when um two parties
are so close we we have to have a clear
winner right when we have a parliament
thing and generally we do almost every
year we do but if one party doesn't have
um doesn't quite hit the they they could
call it going past the post so if they
don't quite go past the post and they
haven't got quite enough of a majority
then what they have to do they have to
Hung Parliament and they basically have
to do a deal with somebody else and we
then get um but so we have two parties
in power and that we basically get
crippled Parliament and that we get four
or five years of chuster doesn't happen
very often but when it does it's a
nightmare because just nothing gets done
yeah they have to they have to have a
deal it happened a few years ago the
conservatives and the liberal Democrats
basically had um they had to team up and
the liberal Democrats forced the
conservatives to do a few things they
didn't want to do because it was part of
the deal and everybody blamed the
liberal Democrats and it destroyed the
liberal Democrat Party it's never
recovered um basically though that's
your Parliament that's your system
because you've got the three
branches and unless they basically they
basically [__] your government
because nothing gets done that's what
happens to us in a hung Parliament and
it's a nightmare it's an absolute
nightmare you can have a lame duck
president the last two years of the
presidency you know seven year seven and
eight the president doesn't do anything
can't do anything because everybody
knows he's on his way
out so there's no you lose that
political leverage that you get in this
country that doesn't happen really
because the prime minister is prime
minister regardless if he loses
popularity he just loses his job and he
goes um there isn't that reaction there
is that there is that ability to react
to in America you've got to wait till
the four years is
up um and they just behave for the last
12 months and people forget yep it it's
the easiest and most BS thing that they
tend to just it's it's tried and true
they do it over and
over yep
anyway I don't know what happened to me
tonight I'm so sorry guys it was fun
though it was fun nonetheless uh we got
you jamming at the beginning and
uh just I like it it was
fun on your channel not mine
too hey we've had consistent people here
the entire time they've all been
chatting it's been fun yeah all good all
good
things I'm I'm looking forward to series
two of Loki 2 I enjoyed the first series
and I can't wait for the second but
let's call it an evening it's been
fascinating next week I promise I will
be good I promise you're good if I
wasn't so add I probably wouldn't let
these things go off in a tangent but
then I I get interested in the tangent
and then the tangent there it happens
when it's on Sidetrack I never let it go
off on tangents I'm quite good at
dragging it back in and staying on topic
so but um yeah we haven't done well it's
night we we've stayed on topic for the
topics we've talked
about the topics just intended to sway
away from Wonder movies yeah it's nine
o'clock it's time for bed it is it is my
well it's time for go and have a cuddle
up with my wife and um watch something
on the TV before we go back have a paint
and enjoy the misses exactly yeah I'm
actually gonna have a melon and um lemon
sber rock and roll baby rock and roll
well uh I guess they know where to
follow us I do want to get better about
like telling like where should we go to
find our Social Media stuff at the end
of stuff obviously ask people to sub
subscribe as well you do need to ask
people to subscribe that too please
subscribe we're we're trying to hit our
monetization to 500 subscribers it'd be
nice to hit like 50 likes on this stream
and and on most streams that'd be cool
uh there are links in the description if
you're watching this on S Trek for
Matt's Channel and most importantly for
Harris's Channel because he's still here
and we don't have to promote Matt's
Channel because he's gone even though it
is Matt's birthday so I suppose we
should but
please well look I want you to hit let's
let's get you hitting 300 subscribers by
the weekend let's really try to do it
all right guys so and we will push again
at the weekend when we're talking um
more sci-fi unless of my slightly
ignorant
opinions so yes let's let's do that
let's let's go push this because your
channel deserves it it's a good Channel
you talk about the stuff we want to talk
about so let's push well thank you and
while while you're just thinking about
sci-fi everybody let us know the second
we end this stream I want to know in the
comments the Creator or Rebel moon like
what what are you looking forward to
legitimately more I because yep kind of
on the Creator side but Rebel moon has
the hype Rebel moon has the hype behind
it Harris haris I need to go for a week
all right I I'll do the outro and uh
just intro again but outro version of it
so yeah like subscribe hit that
notification don't play your a bloody
thingy and um I get the money actually
real quick we got a new
one
okay it's the same thing just with the
country thing so we're going to actually
do the one that you made for this
because it's it's both of us well that's
going to be a um copyright against me
thank you speak to you later guys have
fun we'll see from that first uh song
but thank y'all we will see
[Music]
you